This podcast is brought
to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to know is this.
I have organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them. You sweat through
them, they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me
the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that and Kelly
Starr at loves these shirts as well,
is that you can trick people,
they look really fancy so you can take
them out to nice dinners, whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your
luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently and then pull it out,
throw it on with no ironing,
no steaming,
no nothing.
Walk out and you could probably wear
this thing for a week straight or make it
your only dress shirt and take it on
trips for weeks at a time. Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to four hour work
week.com all spelled out,
four hour work week.com forward
slash shirts check it out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash
shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear including the one shirt
that I've been traveling with.
This episode is brought to you by 99
designs or one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups
that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers
from around the world and here's how it
works. Whether you need a t
shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some
of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com
forward slash Tim optimal
I this altitude, I can flat out for a
half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Living does show what method.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
I deconstruct world class experts,
whether they be chess prodigies,
incredible billionaire investors,
celebrities like Arnold
Schwarzenegger or in this case,
one of the most capable and notorious
computer hackers on the planet who happens
to also be a good buddy of mine,
Sammy Kamkar. He is a beast.
He's also a well known whistle
blower and entrepreneur.
So we could start with what he's
probably best known for her,
which is creating and releasing the
fastest spreading virus of all time,
which was the,
my space worm called aptly enough Sammy.
And of course he was subsequently raided
for it by the United States secret
service. Yes, he was prevented from
touching computers for three years,
but he's also done many other things.
He created skyjack,
which is a custom drone that can hack
into other nearby parrot drones and uh,
basically create a swarm of drones
that someone like Sammy can control
completely. Uh, he's also
known for creating ever cookie,
which appeared in top secret NSA
documents revealed by Edward Snowden.
And he has also spotted some what
you might consider bad behavior.
So He'd discovered elicit mobile phone
tracking where apple and the case of the
iPhone, Google, android and
Microsoft windows phones,
we're transmitting gps and Wifi
information to their parent companies.
And his research on this has led to a
series of class action lawsuits against
the companies and a privacy
hearing on Capitol Hill.
So he is a controversial figure and
for those interested after this, uh,
interview in delving more into a
lot of what I've done with Sammy,
he is one of the experts that I relied
on in the dating game episode of the Tim
Ferriss Experiment, which is the number
one TV season on iTunes. As I record this,
he helped me to hack my online dating
and test a bunch of things that seemed
ridiculous and ended up working and of
course we had Neil Strauss of the game
and a high end matchmaker and
other people that we tested.
But you can check out that episode which
is really fun on itunes.com forward
slash timferriss two RS and two ss.
It's itunes.com forward
slash timferriss Tim, f.
E. R. R. I. S. S.
We also have some bonus footage from
the episode with Sammy that is on vessel
and if you're interested
in content distribution,
this is also just a cool site to check
out and you can go to vessel.com that's v
e s s e l.com forward slash timferriss
and you can find a bunch of videos.
I'll be adding more and uh,
you can see all of these for free for
the next 30 days. Just have to sign up.
So without further ado, I want you
to enjoy the very thought provoking,
terrifying and instructive
conversation with Sammy Kamkar.
Sammy, tell welcome to the
show. Thank you. Awesome.
It is so great to see you again.
It has been awhile since our
adventures and TV land and,
and I wanted to,
I've wanted to introduce you to my fans
and this audience for so long already
and I think a great way to do that is to
explain a few things that are right in
front of me. So you haven't, you
have a necklace on? Yes, I do.
Can you explain what is on your necklace
and I hadn't seen this before today.
Sure, sure. Um, so this is something,
uh, it's actually a microcontroller,
so it's basically a little mini
computer that sits around my neck, um,
that I've programmed to into
something that I call a USB drive by.
And basically what Usb by is is it's
something that I wear around my neck
obviously,
and any computer,
I plugged this into it
within about two seconds,
takes it over forever.
Um,
essentially if you've ever plugged
in the keyboard into your computer,
you know that you can just
start typing keys. Well,
the awesome thing about computers are
that and keyboards that you can do
anything from a keyboard.
You can open windows or Osx.
You can open like a spotlight or start
menu and start typing. You can say,
open a terminal, go into the network
preferences, make all my network traffic,
go to another server.
So now if you plug this in,
all of your Internet traffic,
whatever website you go to,
any email you check goes through my
computer so I can see where you're doing,
where you're going. Um,
additionally, it evades a firewall.
There's like a firewall
where it actually asks,
do you want to allow this
connection to this random servers,
sammy.pl that you've never heard of?
Well, you thanks to this firewall,
you can just hit enter right to hit
the accept button. So it's like, oh,
I'm just going to hit accept. And this
thing is, you know, it's like two inches,
two inches by the interesting,
barely even notice it as
anything other than decorative.
But of course you're not a steam
punk burner. Last I checked.
So it actually has a function. Right,
right. So I've, I've, you know,
I've actually made a video on this.
I've released an entirely open source
for anyone to see how it works,
actually use it.
And the idea is not to actually be
malicious and uses against people,
but to demonstrate sort of the flaws
that exist in our every day computers in
system like USB that have existed for
years and years and years and that we
don't really think about it. Yeah.
I've, you know, and uh, there's,
there's another toy I want to get to in
a second. And which also blew my mind, a,
although didn't entirely surprise me
given the conversations we've had in the
past, but, uh, I,
I at one point was chatting with a former
intelligence officer for think it was
[inaudible] and he now does private
security in a silicon valley.
And other places and he said that if you,
if you were to go to say a Facebook
or a company like that and drop off
malicious USB drives that were branded
with the company logo on them and just
drop them in the lobby where
people check in that you know,
75 to 80% of them will get picked up
and plugged into a computer. Oh sure.
On campus somewhere. But yeah, it
seems like a high percentage, but I,
I believe that,
I mean man,
the problem is you'll plug in, I'll
plug in almost anything. Right.
The lobby is key because you also get
visitors who think they're getting,
they found something valuable.
Oh,
all the dignitaries. Oops.
Yeah, there's a couple,
there's a couple of music artists,
you know,
I love going to shows and then there's
a couple of artists I think like
Bassnectar is thrown out to USB
sticks, which I think is great, right.
With like unreleased music and I just
want to go to Coachella and just throw
these things out
to dry by USB cheeses.
Sammy, you terrify me,
but you also delight me. Tell me, tell
me about this. This other toy is a toy,
right? This is a toy. I mean,
it's not a toy. It's a toy.
It was a toy. It was a toy.
Okay. So this is, uh, you know, I haven't
released any of this stuff out yet.
And where can people find the video? Just
to backtrack for a second. Sure, sure. Um,
my website has everything. So
samy.pl, that's s a m y. Dot. P L
and I will link to all these things in
the show notes as well for everybody.
So this is called the Mattel.
I am me.
This is a product for essentially
tweens and it's this pink,
you know, it was, I call it,
I think it's Fuchsia, but, uh,
it says girl tech on it and you can
essentially text your friends and it's
Mattel, you know, came out
with this many years ago.
So that sort of teen kids could
text their friends, um, without,
you know, finding, you know,
running into the wrong thing creeps and
the wrong people restrict it to who you
can communicate with.
But it happens to have a really cool
wireless chip that a couple other people
out there, I'm Mike Lawson
and a few other people have,
have found that this wireless chip
is actually really, really powerful,
much more powerful than
texting teenage girls. Um,
it's actually able to listen and
transmit on a wide number of frequencies,
including some things that
I found recently, like a
ton of almost all garages,
a high end luxury vehicles.
If you ever used,
let's say a remote, you know,
a lot of cars these days,
you hit a remote town like your
car less. Exactly. Yeah. Um,
so that's all with radio frequency and
normally that's supposed to be encrypted
or at least it's felt to be really hard.
And the thing about security that I've
learned over time is that if we don't see
it, we just assume it's safe. Right?
If you can't see it right away,
if it's not an open door to your house,
right.
As long as you don't know
what's happening. This is kind
of, and I mean, it's true.
Ignorance is bliss, but not until
someone steals your car. Uh,
so this is something that
I've been working on too,
and that's something I've
been demonstrating a and
we'll come out with pretty
soon, um, with being able
to take this Mattel toy,
which is now discontinued, but you
can get on Ebay for pretty cheap. Um,
modify it.
So like here we're actually seeing a
just different frequencies and I'll tell
you and I'll take a photo of this for
you guys as well. Cool. Um, so like,
uh,
Michael Osman is another hacker who builds
a amazing stuff and he's built this a
spectrum analyzer which shows us
frequencies and I've modified it here to
actually record things. So
like if I take a car key, uh,
we'll actually see a spike here whenever
I hit the button. And a lot of cars,
you hit it,
you hit the key to unlock and then you
get in your car and you just press a
button now. And that's wirelessly
communicating with your key as well.
You don't even have to put a key
in the ignition in most cars.
It was very confusing to
me when I first used it.
I just leave it in the
center console or whatever.
We were stuck in there for like 30 minutes
trying to figure out how to turn the
car on. Yeah. Showing my age.
Uh, so essentially that's
also with radio frequency.
You press the button and it sends a signal
to your key to ensure that it's there.
So this device, I've
essentially programmed it to
record that information, um,
and it has to do a few more tricks and
get over a few hurdles and then I can now
start your car, unlock it and
drive away. And fortunately,
this only works on nicer cars.
You know, this is a, I
remember when we did the,
on some of our experiments
in online dating and we'll
definitely talk about some
of your amazing adventures in the
world of online dating. But, uh,
when I did an episode that
involved a breaking into cars,
which is a whole separate story, but, uh,
noticed that a lot of the higher end,
in this particular case,
Japanese vehicles are
really easy to break into,
easier than like old broken down
pickup trucks in some cases.
And it's just astonishing to
realize that in certain cases,
you know,
the security with the most expensive
category of a product is the most
vulnerable. Uh, it's, it just, it really,
it really astonished me to realize that,
well, you find a lot of
Nice neighborhoods. The
doors are unlocked. Oh yeah.
You didn't know exactly ended what I found
in this particular case, this was a, a,
a,
a week of experimenting with
urban invasion and picking
locks and getting into
handcuffs and all this stuff. And, uh,
by the end of two or three days
with a very minimal set of tools,
I could open all of the cars that
the staff had rented who are,
who are working on the show,
including like GMC Yukons and like
some very expensive higher end cars.
Uh, how did you learn to do this
kind of thing? I mean, where,
where did you start to develop this
interest in this skillset? Yeah,
because you have such a breadth,
I mean,
you have familiarity and comfort with
software, obviously, and programming.
But now with hardware,
where did all that start?
The hardware or just the, all the
software hacking. The hacking,
the hacking, I mean it started,
it started early on. Uh,
so yeah, I just live with my
mom when I was younger. Um,
and she worked a lot, you know,
she had, well typically two jobs.
And um,
she got me a computer one day.
It was probably like eight or nine that
she got me like a brand new computer. Um,
and I said, hey mom, you know,
like, can I have internet? Can I go?
And she spent all her money on this or
on this brand new computer because she
knew that I had nothing to do.
Right, right. Has It home is summer,
I know summer camp or anything.
It was just at home. Um,
so she knew how the computers and uh,
she spent everything.
She had to get me a new this computer
and I got the Internet and I was one of
the best days of my life.
And I go on there and I find that man,
there's like so many amazing websites
dedicated to the x files, which,
which was awesome because I love
the x files. So I spent all day on,
on these websites. About the
x files. And I thought, man,
I'd love to really talk to people
about the x files. So I got into a,
I found a message board and I pumped
about the x files. So I posted on there,
it's like, hey guys, I really like,
so I was to let's talk. And I,
he kept hitting refresh, right. He's back
back in the day of message boards. Um,
I guess we still have them, they're
called the forums now. And uh,
I was refreshing and refreshing it or
I wasn't getting the immediate response
like I would on Yahoo or
metacrawler back then when I search.
So I found something
called the chat room IRC.
And I got in there and I went into a
chat room and I was like, hey guys,
I want it.
Who wants to talk about the x files and
which is my favorite show at the time,
if it's not obvious. And, uh,
someone said, get out. I said,
what? What do you mean? I just
wanna I just wanna chat. Okay,
let's just hang out and, and
chalk chat about stuff. He's
like, get out. And I said,
no, I mean, I'm not sure if I said
no, but I didn't. And then he said,
you have 10 seconds to get out.
And he's like, okay, random person,
I don't know on the Internet, where are
you going to do? And 10 seconds later,
something happened,
my computer crashed
and I panicked. I turned
beet red. I s you know,
couldn't speak with sweating and I'd
never encountered a computer crash before,
especially on the first day that my mom
had just bought this and spent all of
her savings and money on this thing,
right.
That I just destroyed potentially.
I waited for like 10 minutes. Uh,
didn't want, didn't want my mom to
find out, disconnected from the power,
connected back in. Thank God is still
worked. And as it was coming up, you know,
adrenaline rushing, kind of like
a fight or flight mode. I said,
that was, that was the coolest
thing ever. How do I do that?
You were hit by a wizard. Yeah. How
do I develop my own magic? Yeah.
And not that I want to destroy
people's computers, but
the, the sh the ability, uh,
the power,
I mean there's something
really intoxicating about
that feeling about being able
to do that. And that's what got me down
to say, okay, well how do I do that?
And then what was the
next step after that?
The next step I learned about these
things called dos attacks now of service.
And this was like windows 95,
right?
It was a long time ago and I was going
to say it's pretty good one to attack
the, you know, I download a program
that did this and then windows, uh,
Adidas, just, no, just a
dos. Okay. Not distributed.
New DDoSs is like a newer thing.
Um,
maybe that came out in like
10 years ago because dos is,
we're no longer effective.
Right.
This was just a dos attack and a
denial of service, denial of service,
making a website unavailable
to other people. Exactly.
Website or computer or computer. Yeah.
And this wasn't even overwhelming.
It was just a,
a specially crafted packet that you had
said to somebody and Microsoft patched
in one day. And I was like,
oh no, my, my mat, why wizard?
My electronic letter bomb doesn't work
anymore. Exactly. And I said, well,
someone devise a way to create
this program. How can I do that?
How can I make my own, it was called wind
nuke. How can I make my own wind nuke?
So I then learned how exactly.
So back then you called it nuking
it not dossing nuking. And uh,
I started learning how that specially
crafted packet him modified memory on a
windows computer and properly corrupted
something in the kernel and then would
cause it to crash. What is the
kernel just for those not familiar,
which might include me, I've heard
the word a lot. Sure. The kernel is,
is basically just the brain.
It's the brain of a computer
typically. Um, so, uh, uh,
typically more advanced operating
systems like windows, Mac, Linux,
they'll have a kernel that
handles all the system functions.
Like it makes sure your keyboard
works and your monitor works, um,
versus your normal software that
sits on top of the colonel. Got It.
And that from there,
I mean I had learned how to uh,
learn how to start running software. And
a lot of it also came from gaming. Um,
you know, I played counter strike a
lot, actually got into quake and doom,
then quake,
then counterstrike,
it's probably like 14 playing
counterstrike all day and all night. Uh,
and I was, you know, I played so much
that I got good, but it wasn't the best.
I thought,
how could I be the best and and playing
one day and I had two speakers left and
right and someone comes up behind me and
in counter strike you can see where all
your teammates aren't.
You have like a little radar,
a heads up display where you can see
your teammates but you can't see enemies.
And I heard footsteps,
they came from my right speaker and then
came and then you pan to the my left
speaker.
But I didn't see someone on my radar,
so I knew if they're not on my radar,
it must be an enemy.
But since I couldn't see them,
they must be behind me.
And I thought about that for a moment.
There's information going from my
right speaker two I left speaker.
That means there must be positional
information about the enemy.
How do I get access to that?
So that's when I learned the fact that
these packets from these other players
are coming to my computer
over the Internet and they
have positional information
of where to play footsteps.
So if you have surround sound,
you'll properly here how far,
how you know the amplitude,
the volume of those footsteps
and where it should we panned.
And once I understand a understood and
learned about packet sniffing where you
can just see the packet, see to the
actual traffic going over the Internet,
I could then locate every person
that on the map, enemy or friend.
So I then created my own cheat software
and that placed everyone on the map.
I mean I could see through walls,
I actually added opacity.
I started learning about how to
reverse engineer. I'm the open GL,
which was the graphics
library that was used.
So all the graphics that are displayed
when when something says it should be a
wall, I said, you know what? You should
actually have a 50% alpha transparency.
I should be able to see
through it a little bit.
You see some Guy Drowsy,
a superman. Yeah, exactly.
See some guy crouching and behind a box
and I know exactly where he's crouching.
So I just run and do like a matrix flying,
jump and shooting, you know, a headshot.
And then the game wasn't fun
anymore. Um, and actually, you know,
soon after that I was
probably 15 at that point.
There's a software called punk buster.
And just to, just to take a quick pause,
you were in Pittsburgh, where were
you at the time? 15. So I was born,
I was born in Pittsburgh. Correct
when I was 13. My mom was like,
do you want to move to la? And I
said, okay. And uh, we got in there,
we got in her car and moved to Los
Angeles because she wanted to be in la.
And I thought that was cool.
It's a hell of a drive. Okay.
So 15 that's interrupted. So now
you're in La at this point? Yeah.
15 Nla and like Arcadia,
Pasadena area. Um,
and at this point is about far enough
that I had kind of had enough of high
school, um, not for any good
reason. I just didn't enjoy it.
So I just stopped going. Uh, my mom
was working a lot, so they like,
cause she was at work.
I mean she can tell me not to.
So I would go, I would just stay
home and play counterstrike, uh,
and then work on cheats and
characteristic immediately became unfun.
I don't know if you've ever played with
cheats, but like when you have cheat,
when you have this God mode, it's
not fun anymore. And fortunately,
God mode should be the name of your
memoir by the way when you write it.
So as soon as this, uh, as soon as the
cheap, as soon as, as it using the cheat,
I would also release it as open source
so anyone else could use it and just see
how to do this kind of
stuff. Uh, I found, uh,
they actually created this software
called punk buster that prevented my cheat
from working. And all of a sudden it
became fun again because now it was,
it was like a cat and mouse game.
How do I modify my software
so that they can't detect it?
And we went back and forth. So I'd
release a new version that's fun software.
Very.
So the game became the cloak and
dagger defeating of the punk buster.
Yeah. And similar applications. They're
similar software and I mean it was that,
you know, at this point I'm
fighting against it, you know,
a company full of employed developers
and engineers and I get to sit in my room
and just, uh, play against
them. Right. And that,
that I would say, taught me to understand
this stuff kind of pretty, you know,
at that point,
just a understanding how to break down
a problem and how to break down those
types of problems.
Reverse engineering,
you're trying to modify something that
you don't actually have the source code
to, you know, uh, counterstrike
wasn't open source.
So when you hit a wall or
had a block of some type,
how would you learn? How would
you problem solve? How would you,
how would you try to address that?
Uh, if I hit a block of some sort.
So I think,
uh,
I think it broken down things too.
I pretty much, if I have a problem,
whatever that may be, whether it's
technological or in, in life, uh,
and I will take something and I
will try to look at two things,
inputs and outputs and
that's how everything in a
computer works. And that's,
that's why I think this way probably
there are always the number of endpoints
puts sometimes none,
but there Stickley's that goes in and
something that comes out and I usually
want something to come out a certain
way. Um, and I look at that and I say,
what else comes out that way?
Under what input conditions?
Can I make something come out this way?
Have I actually tested all the possible
input conditions you might think with
the computer? Okay, well
if I give it, you know,
if I want to take something out of memory,
if I went to like read a program
that I'm not supposed to,
what are all the inputs I
can like mash the keyboard?
I can send every possible key stroke,
maybe there's no keyboard,
how can I use the mouse in a certain way?
But then you think you just
think a little bit further.
Like what if you take all those easily,
readily available inputs away,
what other inputs are available.
And then you start to think
about like the environment.
What about the temperature?
You know,
if you actually three is if you actually
take nitrogen and apply it to a memory,
you can freeze memory and then
you can pull it out. Uh, you know,
they didn't have to do
this with, uh, with uh,
Ross Albridge, uh, Alberta and if
I'm pronouncing that properly, uh,
the Silk Road, uh, you
didn't have to, but if you,
that's a whole separate story who was
apprehended less than five miles from my
house. It's such a
crazy story. Yeah, yeah,
no, definitely. Sorry.
Continue. Oh, um, so yeah,
I'd say pretty much looking at all the
possible ways I can send information and
I can control the input.
That's, that's how I, uh,
what would be an example of that from
your counterstrike days or any other days?
What would be sort of a real
world example of, of how you say,
all right,
hold on a second.
Let me look at the inputs and outputs
in this particular scenario. Okay, sure.
Um, so let's take, uh,
something new and new that I'm working
on right now that has some demonstrations
up. Um, and that's
hijacking cars. Perfect.
So, uh, first it was how
can we start cars? Like how,
what, what is my goal, right?
What is my intention? Um,
and obviously my goal
is not to steal cars,
but to just show fallacies in ways that
we can protect against this as well. Uh,
but to protect against it, you
have to understand it, right? Um,
so how do I start my car normally and
I'm looking at these cars were, uh,
you either use a key or
you don't use a key. Now,
when cars that use a key,
it's actually pretty simple because
it's pretty easy to replicate keys. Uh,
there's plenty of bump keys available,
the number of ways to break
into the car bump keys make,
make getting into cars really easy.
You've learned that.
You've learned that my car safe out there,
it's gone.
That's all right. I want to
have it for long. Awesome. Uh,
so that's, uh, and that's,
and that's actually really
interesting. A lot of hackers,
you know, every year there's a really
big conference in Vegas called Def Con.
It's been going on over 20 years and they
actually have a huge lock picking area
where it's cool. Yeah. And it's not
even, a lot of them are hackers.
A lot of them aren't. A lot of them
are just straight lock pickers.
That's what they do. They want to
be able to break every type of lock.
And it's very much the same as
hacking. Right? It's how, what,
how can we control the environment in a
way to produce the output that we want
this, you know, tumble, lock, turning. Um,
even though I don't have the
proper equipment, the key,
so for the car it's like,
okay, well I'm pushing a button that must
be doing something and I know that it
communicates with my key somehow.
I don't know. I don't know how, um,
because there's nothing else,
because one of my keys not there and I
push a button, the car does not start.
I you're talking about the non insertion
key in this case. Yeah, correct.
For in this case,
I'm talking about the non insertion
key just because the doing it with the
insertion key has been done over and
over again. Right. Um, so now it's the,
the newer models of everything. Or now
you don't have a key that you insert.
You just keep it in your pocket.
So as long as you have the key on you,
you can start the car. So I wanted to
say, okay, well how is that communicating?
And, uh, I look at the key
and in some cases the key,
we'll actually have like a model number
in the u s you actually have the FCC,
you're actually regulated where you can,
what you can transmit and receive.
So pretty much any device, you know what
the band is, you know what the band is.
If you look at it loved back of any phone,
it'll have an FCC id.
And at least in the u s oh yeah.
Look I think is looking at
the back of an iPhone. Yup.
And because it transmits and receives,
so from here you can actually look,
look up that a band like you
said, right. The frequency band.
Then you look at how can I listen
to that frequency band. Um,
and I found some devices, I found
some. Awesome. Would you just Google,
how do I listen to Xyz band or like I
mentioned earlier, I Google everything.
Okay.
Can you share what we were talking about?
My car is really small and
it's loads go you specific.
It's very low. It is
low. It's a Lotus Lotus,
which I just like scrambled and struggled
to get out of earlier and just look
like a complete idiot
trying to get out of it.
It's a great car but it's very hard for
me to get out of. So yeah, the top is on.
It's pretty hard to get out of
when the top is on. And uh, I man,
when I got it, I loved it. Um,
that's another time I really use Google
immediately because I'd never driven
stick before. So they shipped it
to me, they delivered it at uh,
like there's some place in Hollywood
and I had to drive it home and I'd never
driven stick sitting sitting in it
on my iPhone looking at like Wiki,
how.com, I think some, you know,
I googled how do I drive stick
and that's so I learned on the way
I didn't learn well that's a hard,
that's a really rough entry into
manual transmission. Yeah. Drove,
drove home, stalled a few times
on the one and a half miles home.
But um,
I got out and just was an idiot and just
like stumbling for five minutes trying
to figure out how to pull myself out
of these buckets. Seats because yeah,
it's just,
it's kind of like,
imagine that you have like your pants
pulled down to just above your knees and
you go down to a full squat and then
you have to like dive forward. It's,
it's like ergonomically very similar.
So you googled know I drove it around
the first week and man I've pulled up
somewhere nice place,
a bunch of people and my brand new car
about this and this felt good and not
just a brand new car. Brandon
Lotus, brand new lotus.
And I'm like this,
this feels good.
I opened the door and I
like struggle and I'm like,
should I just get back in and drive away?
I think some people saw me.
So after a week of this
embarrassment I Google,
how do I get out of a lotus?
And to my surprise and delight,
people have documented how I found a
youtube video that was very instructional.
I gave it a like,
um,
I did not believe a comment
that I needed to learn,
but I learned how to get out of my car
through the youtube video and online
because it was, it's just
really embarrassing. And
Yeah, I learned how to you,
I've used one arm,
you use one hand on the steering wheel
and you pull that cause that is firmly
connected to the car as the other
hand on the side of the chair.
And then you just thrust,
thrust of your arms,
you urge you superman out of the phone to,
yeah,
he's superman and then
smoothly catch your balance.
And the sort of the parallel
here with the band, if,
if you look at the back of a phone or
device, the back of a key and you're like,
oh, look at this, there's
an FCC registration, right?
And I can identify with the band and the
frequency band is right for this, uh,
this wireless key,
right,
for whatever brand x car happens to be.
Uh,
and then the next step is googling or
determining how to listen in on their
frequency. Correct. And you know,
you don't, if you don't know that,
I don't know much about frequency
bands, but I know that, you know,
when you're listening to FM radio,
that's a frequency band FM that's actually
frequency modulation. It's a type of,
it's a way to communicate
data's am amplitude modulation,
amplitude modulation it, they actually
adjust the way that they're sending data.
Amplitude is like volumes. So they're
changing the volume to send data.
We're frequency to actually
changing the frequency.
So when you listened to one oh 5.9 FM,
you're listening to one oh 5.9 megahertz.
And your,
the,
the frequency is actually changing
from one oh 5.8 to one oh 5.106.
That's actually why, you
know, you can listen to FM
radio a little bit off, right?
Sometimes you hear FM if you're
a little off. So, uh, that's,
that's another frequency. And a lot
of these actually car keys use am,
um, they're not an aim that a
radio in a car with listened to,
but they are a m so it's size of the
way of not the number of the waves in a
given timeframe. For amplitude, it's,
it's essentially like how much, uh,
how powerful that wave is. I
see. It's like volume, right?
It's like yelling versus being quiet.
Right? Um, so that's the different in,
in amplitude modulation is just
a fancy word for change. So,
and uh, and then we'll do the next
step after that. It's not, so,
yeah.
So I found a few different devices that
I can use that are low cost and a couple
people, you know, a couple of security
researchers have made a lot of this stuff,
uh, readily available. I mean, uh,
it was other researchers who found that
you can use this Mattel toy to actually
listen to and wide number of frequency
bands, right. Rather than, you know,
in the past just a few years ago,
it costs thousands,
thousands of dollars to get something
that could listen to all of the frequency
bands that like something like this would
output and for you to actually access
all that data.
So once I got to a device like this,
I'm actually able to see the data.
I can actually get turn,
turn that when you press that button
and it sends a signal in 433 megahertz,
um, that I can see that data,
what that binary data is.
And if I send it a bunch,
I hit the button a bunch of times,
then I see it over time and I see
what changes, what doesn't change.
And I can make assumptions because then
I can compare it to another car and say,
Oh wow, this beginning is always
the same between these two cars.
So that must mean it's this type of car.
Uh,
but this part here is
different between the two cars.
So that must mean this one specifically
for this car and this other identifier
is for this other car.
And usually there's actually,
there actually is decent
security in most cars.
It's called rolling codes where
the code changes every time.
It's kind of like a Google authenticator
or something like that. Yeah, yeah.
It's um, it's a, yeah, it's
like an additional factor
of authentication where the,
the number changes.
So if I,
let's say there's only a thousand possible
ids or passwords that would work to
open this car, turns his car on.
If you send id 10 it turns on,
but the next, but if I
listened to that and replay it,
replay that 10, it says, oh,
I've already seen 10 we're on a new code
now, so it's not going to allow that.
So that was the first problem I ran
into where I can't send the same code.
So if you go up to your
car and you turn it on,
I can listen and I can store that.
But if I replay it,
it's not going to work because
the car knows that that's been,
that code's been used.
Now is the car recognizing,
is it the uh,
frequency or the tune effectively of that,
like good quick cook,
that type of uh,
electronically like a bird song that
is triggering the car. Therefore,
if it didn't change from
a 10 to whatever was next,
you'd be able to replay that
sound auditorily? Uh, not,
not with audio. Okay. I
mean, so, um, audio is a,
is a, is essentially vibration
of air, right? Where uh,
this is radio frequency. I see. Right.
So the audio is really just a cue for the
human to be like, exactly. It's my key.
My key did something. Yeah. Yeah. It's
just a really silly sound that they used,
which I like to reenact.
Some of you may have noticed that will
increase with the moral wine that we have
most likely. Got It. So you ran into
the problem that this is, this is,
this is a rolling code prefix or whatever
it might be. That's changing over time.
But there's,
there's a couple of exploits here.
There's a couple of
possible vulnerabilities.
If your away from your car,
if you're not close to it and you
hit the button and I capture that,
I can play it.
So if I came into your house and I had
my device and I pressed the button on
your key,
I can then record it because your car
is far enough that it didn't see that.
So now I can use the code,
right?
But that's not good enough
because now me in your house,
I have access to your key.
That seems a,
it seems like I already have physical
access them. I just live here.
It's a brute force approach.
It forcetech. Uh, so, uh,
that's just not good enough as an
exploit. Really familiar, at least for me.
So I want to take it from very
elegant. It's not elegant at all. Um,
so how can we make this better?
Now,
another thing that I've
seen is that these fee,
a lot of these devices
are very inexpensive. The,
they don't want to spend
too much on these parts.
They want to make it work and work well.
Um,
so if you actually send a bunch
of other data on that frequency,
it will not work because now the car's
confused and it sees too much information.
Now if you stop,
you could call that jamming and you don't
need to send a big signal. But I could,
if you take another car
with that communicates on
the same frequency with the
key and you just hold down your lock
button while someone else is trying to get
into their car, you'll prevent
them from getting into their car.
Oh my God. So you can actually hold and
for totally different manufacturers,
most of them are using the same frequency
because it only certain frequency
bands you can use fixed and stuff.
So if you see someone and you have like a,
like I was using a Cadillac,
a car key,
and it transmits so far.
If you have one of those really powerful
transmitters that hits your car from
far away and you just hold unused
hold lockdown, it's holding lock.
So you could just sit in the parking
garage drinking, drinking your coffee,
holding down the lock button,
watching people lose their shit.
You got the not being able to turn
on their cars sitting in there.
So ostensibly, is there a way,
and this is just me with my, uh,
my science fiction cap on a or
conspiracy theorist calf on perhaps, uh,
is, is there a sensibly
a way if they're limited,
if that band is so uniform that someone
could deploy some type of a wide
reaching jamming to incapacitate cars
over an extended period of time? Um,
yes. I mean you need a lot
of power, right? The further,
the further you want to go, you
need a lot of power. That's why,
that's why FM stations, right,
they have such big towers. Um,
a m can actually go longer.
Uh,
and so there are a couple of ways
that you can do this. Um, but yeah,
you could with enough
power and an antenna,
you could prevent a lot of
cars from starting. Wow.
Uh, at least if it requires,
if it's using the radio frequency based
stuff right now, not in normal key,
normal key will work fine.
And I'm sure there are people out
there listening to this who are asking
themselves,
why on earth would these
security researchers make
these exploits known to the
general public? Isn't that just
giving a blueprint to be blue,
want to exert malice in the world
or create chaos? AndW how would you,
how would you respond to that?
I mean,
that's an infant now keeping
in mind and full disclosure,
I'm one of those kids who bought the
anarchist cookbook and was looking at like
improvise munitions and put himself in
advertently on every watch lists on the,
in, in the, in the domestic United States.
But, uh, so I'm fascinated by exploits.
I find them infinitely interesting.
But at the same time, you know,
this is a question that comes up. So
yeah, yeah. Fair. Say, Oh, what as a kid,
I was like 12.
Then once I was 12,
I had my own website and I
found the anarchist's cookbook.
So I put a copy of it up cause
I thought this was awesome.
And one day my mom comes home from like,
one of her jobs is like Sammy,
like someone at work was look, you know,
found this thing on your website. And uh,
he was actually looking up this thing,
anarchist cookbook and found on
your website like, why are you,
why do you have this thing? I
was like, well it's awesome,
but why was he looking like he had
found it inadvertently? Not On my site,
but just through a wave is searching
for it. Cause I don't know.
I'm not sure. And I mean it's interesting
information, but you ask a question,
you ask a good question, right? Um,
is this a blueprint for, you know,
malicious people to act upon? And
it can be, but I don't think so.
And the reason I say this is a,
I've been doing,
I've been in security and hacking
long enough that many years ago.
What I would do is I,
if I found a new exploit,
I would sometimes I would contact the
company and I would let them know about
this and say, Hey, like totally
fried. Just just want to let you know,
I found this vulnerability.
You guys should patch this
because it's uh, you know,
battered customers, your customer data
could be leaked, you could be hacked,
it could hurt you. Um, I haven't
done anything. I just found it.
And sometimes you get a
response, sometimes you
don't, sometimes they fix it,
sometimes they don't.
And then I found they found some other
vulnerabilities and then I would write
publicly about it and say, hey, like,
here's some things that we need to fix.
This is a general problem, not something
I can just email a company about. And,
you know,
nothing would really happen.
A couple of security people would
read my blog and say, oh, neat.
That's like some really interesting
information. Thank you Sammy.
And nothing changes. Um, and
then one day I said, you know,
like nothing ever changed.
A lot of these things don't change when I,
when I talk about them,
when I contact the right,
the proper people who have the block,
when you're going through
official channels,
when I can do it going through official
channels. So I released this time,
not only a blog and this is uh,
there was something I released a few
years ago and it's called the ever cookie.
And essentially what this does is it
plants a tracking cookie on your computer.
Kind of like when you go
to a website and you know,
if you go to Google and you make a search
and then you go back to Google a week
later,
it knows who you are and knows that you
did that search last week and that's
through a cookie,
but you can delete your cookies.
And I found that some
companies we're also doing,
they would install a different type of
cookie called like a flash cookie so that
if you deleted your normal cookies,
they would still know who you are.
It's a bit surreptitious. That's creepy.
Yeah, it's a little, a little creepy. And,
uh,
you know,
a number of people knew about this for
many years and it got talked about and
talked about and talk about for years. I
thought, I mean, these aren't, you know,
someone had released a little bit
of software to try to prevent it.
And I thought there's some
other ways of doing this.
And I was in Dublin at the time,
first time I left the U s we're
talking about earlier and I, uh,
I thought it'd be cool to create
something that can really plant itself,
like in every possible way that I can
think of. And I sat down and was like,
there's gotta be at
least four or five ways.
And I thought about for about 14 or 15
ways to plant software, or not software,
but a unique identifier that will then
track you every time you come back to
that website or any site that has the
tries to attract you using that software.
So it would install a unique
identifier in your cookies,
in your flash cookies and your Silverlight
and Java in your history and your
cash just everywhere. And if you
deleted almost everything except one,
it would then respond.
It would recreate everywhere.
So you could never get rid of it.
Literally most rousers
could not get rid of this.
So if someone wants to track you,
they would always be tracking your web
presence at least on those sites that
hosted.
And this got it.
Press this.
I mean this was interesting to the
security community because the security
community had been talking about this for
years, but no one really listened. Uh,
people had been demonstrating companies
that were doing more mediocre measures
of this though. What University
version. Exactly. Yeah.
That they were going Jv. And
this was finally something that
anyone could use entirely open source.
I made entirely free, um, kind
of a lot of hate mail for.
But what was interesting was it was a few
months later that every browser vendor
had changed.
Every major browser had changed.
I don't know if you remember a few
years ago when you want to delete your
history, you deleted in one place.
If you want, delete your cash.
You have to go into a different
dropdowns and delete it there.
If you want to delete your, uh, down the
recent downloads you go somewhere else,
all of this stuff was
segregated and no cute,
no sane person would actually go
to all through all this effort.
Now when you delete your
privacy information,
it's all centralized sort of file one
privacy, one checklist, one checklist.
And that's,
I saw that change and that's probably
the biggest thing that made that impacted
me to understand this
actually produces change. Yes.
Maybe someone will be able to use
it maliciously for a little bit,
but you know what,
people have been using it maliciously
for years and no one actually knows that
because talking about it
doesn't do enough. Okay.
Yeah. It's not just enough to talk. Yeah.
And you need people to listen and
there are definitely different,
different levers you can pull to
make that more effective. Sure.
So speaking of which,
uh, and I, I do want to,
if you're open to it,
a chat about my space at one point
because that's a hell of a story.
Oh my God. Folks, don't go away.
Coming right back. Uh, the,
the next subject I thought we could,
we could dig into a little bit is,
is a online dating.
So getting people to listen.
Uh, we had a lot of fun with the, uh,
the episode on Tim Ferriss Experiment,
which is now digitally available by
the time people are listening to this,
which is amazing. After so much
effort and lawyering and everything,
uh,
we'd a lot of fun on that episode.
And you take this same scientific approach
and I really feel like what you do
is, uh, using the scientific method,
it really at a high level to,
to attack some of these,
these engineering problems and challenges,
uh,
in the world of mating and dating. So, uh,
could you talk about some of the,
some of the ways you have thought
about online dating and improved your
prospects online dating? And we
can dig from there. All right.
I don't even know where to begin.
My, my mind is flooded with,
with all the possibilities that we
could discuss. Okay. So, so I used, um,
I used online dating, maybe I'd done a
long time ago, 10 years ago, 11 years ago.
And, uh, I,
I met someone great and had a great
relationship for a few years and that was
awesome. And, um, I think I got
back to it maybe, let's see.
I think five or six
years ago I had gotten,
you know, meeting people.
It's frustrating. Uh,
I wanted to meet, meet more women. So
I thought, okay, I'll, I'll do online.
Did again. I had good
experience. It was painted,
it was hard as a lot of work is painful,
uh,
but also fun at times and it was
successful. So I thought, okay,
I'll do it again.
So I went on sort of the hip dating site
at the time and I had that was okcupid.
Okcupid.
Yeah.
And I made a profile on there a few
years ago and I started reaching out to
people, um, doing searches and
you know, I was doing a lot of,
I have also a lot of work.
I had a lot of stuff to do in my life.
A lot of stuff I like doing.
I did not like going messaging people,
not getting messages back scrolling,
just like scrolling through endless lists,
having so many,
so much data to go through and
then not even knowing whether,
I mean, I guess the biggest problem was
I wasn't getting messages back. Right?
And I'm like, what happened?
I thought I was eligible,
puts the failure point in there and
you're like, dammit. So I thought, okay,
well, you know, how would I,
how would I approach this?
And this was after a few
frustrating weeks, I thought,
how would I approach this if
this were a problem with my,
let's say my company's
website or something.
What if I were trying to
make sales online? Um, how,
how would I approach this differently?
And I thought, okay, well if I,
if I were doing something for my own
company or my own business or on my own
product or whatever,
I would probably,
I'd start with some basic ab
testing or multivariate testing. Um,
I would try comparing what one group
of people did versus another group of
people. So I didn't have, I didn't
want to spend too much time in this,
but I wrote a little script and all
that did was every day that would cycle,
that would change my photo,
my primary photo and uh,
okay Cupid, we'll show you how
many hits you would get that day.
So everyday I would check back and that
it's stored in a database and you know,
I had it, I had throw up a couple of my,
you know, bad photos just as a, I dunno,
control or something and had my,
my best photos and some medium photos.
My best photos were awful.
They were terrible.
I thought performance without performance.
Why?
What I thought looked great with this
stupid smirk on my face was terrible just
by bombs. Right. No one clicked. Right.
And this isn't in searches
and probably messages as well.
Nobody clicked the photos that I thought
were good and a couple of these photos
that I just thought were mediocre,
subpar,
just they got clicks and there's
certain certain things I learned that,
I mean, I will say our chick
crack. Yeah. Things that, you know,
when guys see certain things
on the website, they click any,
their brain shuts off and they click
and there are the same things for girls.
So what are, what are some of those
things? Well, um, the thing that did best,
I mean just land slide was
a picture of me and a cat
sitting on my shoulder.
So they weren't clicking for me and this
had nothing to do with me. Let me, let's,
let's be clear. It was, they
saw a cat, but that's okay.
I'm just trying to get you one step
further, right? Once it further word,
then you can learn a little bit of my
personality. Maybe you'll, you know,
you'll try to read this,
uh, this text I put up. Uh,
so that was that instantly after learning
that I was just blown away. I was like,
wow, I've been doing this
wrong. I am not as, uh,
I have no idea what other people like
apparently. Um, and that's fair. I mean,
I don't, so I should use data and try to
help help myself and help other people.
I mean, I think this is,
this is beneficial. And A,
we did some absurd permutations of this
for the TV show. I'm not going
to spoil it. Uh, but we, uh,
we went for the gold with some of
these proof opics uh, the, of you,
the big to be clear.
And there were other people involved,
like Neil Strauss who really
was not in favor of any of this,
but, uh, who's the author of the game?
For those people who don't know the, the,
what are,
what are some of the,
now at one point you didn't you create
a female profile to observe what came in
as inbound in terms of,
absolutely. I mean, I'll, I'll
start with this. I'm, I'm not,
um, I tried to be as transparent and
honest with people. Um, I, you know,
I hate deception and I don't
try to deceive people, but
for ab testing, it's, it's,
it's for science. So I
created a profile of, uh, uh,
of what I thought would be someone
I would like to date. Right.
Someone who's attractive. Um, what is you,
what did you call her? Do you remember?
Oh, I don't know. I'd have
to look that up. All right
here. I'm pretty sure I stole.
I'm pretty sure I stole another girl's
username. And then you changed a number.
Got It. Um, I used a text from
a profile that I really liked.
They use a friend's pictures
who allowed me to, and uh,
I put that up just to see what if I
were a female that I personally would be
attracted to. What are they
experiencing on an online dating site?
Because I have no idea.
I thought my woody messages would
really wear it can they weren't. So,
you know, I'd, I'd always
start with the subject hello.
And then a really great message and a,
after the first day I got over,
nope.
Close to a hundred messages,
close to a hundred emails as
this, you know, attractive,
interesting female.
That's, I mean, terrible.
There's no possible way anyone's going
to go through all these messages.
And now I'm looking at the messages
and the first thing I see is the same
subject over and over and over that I
probably use over and over and over.
They're all saying basically four
thing, three or four things. Um,
hello my idea, you know,
hey wink, winky face, um,
thought we should chat
and wanna fuck nice.
It's a strong,
it's a strong opener and it's actually
all of those were used a lot. It was that,
it was surprising and I
felt that I was offended.
I as a fake female on this website
has offended. And I thought, wow,
like these are all the say
they're all the same. Right.
Even if it were interesting, if it's
all the same, then it's irrelevant.
So I immediately learned,
okay,
my subject line has to be different and
that's be interesting as we, you know,
not offensive and it has to be not boring.
Um,
so then I went into another city.
I wanted to actually another state
and I tried mailing lots of people,
different subject lines as a man,
right.
As my own profile and estate
that I wasn't even in.
I'm not actually going to meet these
people. I'm sorry if I emailed you,
but I just wanted to know what subjects
had the best read rates and then
response rate.
Um,
I found a little exploit that allowed
me to get the read rate because normally
you can't see how many people open your
message. Right? And once I found this,
I found how many people open a message
and then I can also track how many people
responded, right? And that the open
rate allows me to measure how well,
how good is the subject
doing the subject line.
And I tested a ton of different subject
lines to see what worked best and uh,
I'm sorry to say it, uh, and
I've been trying to curse less,
but the best subject line was fuck you.
Now not saying that,
that,
that obviously not elicit a
positive emotional response,
but that's not immediately the goal.
That's on immediately the goal. And,
and that's okay because,
and I found if you're
still a dick in the email,
the response rate is zero or
very little and some mean things.
And I don't think you should ever be
mean to someone. And my intention again,
is not to be mean.
I'm trying to see,
it's like clapping in front of their
face really, really hard openness.
And I found the best research,
the best way to get a response
in a positive response is to say,
I only did that.
So you'd read this message,
you're probably getting a ton of emails
from other guys that are saying, hey,
or want to fuck. And she's
like, how did he know?
How did he know? Exactly.
So, so it's really, I mean,
it's just trying to understand
what someone else is going
through and how can I,
how can I knew her that better? And then
also, ultimately I'm always transparent.
You know, whenever I meet anyone, I tell
them whenever I meet anyone, I tell them,
uh, you know, exactly all the, all
the tactics, just because, I mean,
if anything else, it's interesting
conversation, especially with a woman. Um,
it really, it, it was the best first date.
Every time you just get
to talk about something,
like immediately you have
something to talk about.
You're both on this dating site,
you're both trying to meet somebody and
you're both upset about the results.
However,
how inefficient the whole thing is so
immediate that that was always really
positive. So, yeah. You know, I, I'm not,
I'm not suggesting me an asshole. I'm,
but I am suggesting that a,
it's good to learn about ways to,
you know,
just be a maneuver past and actually
get someone to read you read that letter
and see whether you are an interesting
person, whether you would drive,
we know with,
uh,
with online dating for someone
who does not have technical chops.
So super someone who cannot personally
doesn't have the capacity to write
scripts or whatnot.
Uh,
what would your advice to
them be in this day and age?
That's great because there's, there's a
wide variety of toolkits available, right?
You have the Okcupid's is the
match.com Tinder. Oh, sure, of course.
Uh,
what would your advice to,
to a nontechnical person B,
and let's assume for the sake of argument
that since they would waste as a guy,
you're going to waste hundreds of dollars
on drinks and dinners that go nowhere.
So let's assume they have a budget. Okay.
A little bit of a budget, like 500 bucks.
Okay. What would your advice
to them be? Okay. So, uh, the,
the first thing you do is you get
a record player and you take a,
you take your iPhone and you
attach one of those, um, those,
those pens that have the conductive tip.
So you can draw on your iPhone with it
and you attach it to the record player
and you put Tinder beneath it.
So the record player just spins and just,
you know how you swipe right,
swipe over to them.
I saw the video of this and it was
the funniest thing I've ever seen.
Somebody who attach this little nub to
a record player that would just swipe on
Twitter. Tinder. I thought that was
really funny. Okay. No, so realistically,
I don't know, the site might
not be around anymore, but um,
instead of writing a program, you can use
a site like hot or not, or if there are,
there are any sites like that, that, you
know, unfortunately measure appearance,
but that's important.
It's very important to your photo is
the most I learned Okcupid critical,
which allows you to upload
the photos to do, uh,
my cupid or my best face. They have
that now. Correct. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
So, uh, my best, you're right.
My best face on Okcupid allows you to
essentially do the same thing where you
can upload a number of photos, you
rate other people's photos essentially,
and other people rate yours.
So it's a,
it's a really cool system
where you learn what, you know,
what a photos of you or most attractive.
And I found the photo of
Brad Pitt was my most of
the right picture of my picture of a
Jason Statham with just doing a scrooge
McDuck backstroke.
And a pool of money was
trying to buy penguins.
I don't know the why the penguins were so,
so first identify which photos
work the best for them. The photos,
the first thing anyone sees,
and we did this in the episode too,
so there's a for people who
want to see how off I was,
how incredibly off I was
in my predictions. Uh, you,
you can check that out. It's on
iTunes probably at this point, but uh,
so you identify your best photos.
Absolutely. What's next? Okay.
So now if you, if you're a low, any light,
if you're like me and had a terrible
photo, you're now receiving messages.
So you're already here already, like
happy. Um, but if that's not enough,
you need to because you know, you're, you
need to be a little bit more selective.
Um, so what's next is I would say
testing different subject lines. Um,
you know,
I,
I wanted to test so many people that I
went to a different state and I automated
that. But you can, you can
test it yourself, right?
You can use the same message and some
of these services allow you to pay a
little extra to see read
rates and open rates and um,
essentially analytics for
your dating profile. Uh, pay,
pay that extra amount and make changes
make changes often and record that data
always recorded, keep it an XL
spreadsheet. You will learn so much. Um,
so the next thing is how do
you communicate, um, the,
this is just the way it is.
If you're a guy,
you need to be reaching out to
people, right? And you should be,
if you haven't figured that out yet,
the hot chicks and not going to come
knocking on your door. I hate to tell Ya,
if you want to be selective,
you need to work for it. So,
so I'm testing different
subject lines and uh,
another thing that I learned,
the,
that you should use immediately
is while messages are great, uh,
what I found was very,
was really,
really effective as you could go messaging
for weeks with someone who's really
interesting and if you're,
if the service you're using a has
chat, like Okcupid has chat, chat,
you know,
select people as your favorites so you
see them whenever they're online. Um,
don't stock them. Just like when you
see them once, then talk to them,
communicate with them. And
what's a good opener, uh,
in your experience? Uh, I, I tried to make
it relevant to their profile. Right? You,
you, you don't want to appear
like you don't want to use,
you don't want to be the people who
don't actually read the text. Right?
You actually want to learn
about that person. Right?
There's a high probability she's looking
for someone who has read the text,
who has read her profile. Right?
She put it in time on that.
You put in time on that, so read it.
Um, don't, you know, if you're just,
you might find you might
not like this person.
So read the texts and then trying to,
you know,
try and make some simple conversation.
I would say immediately the best thing
I learned is it's not even about the
opener at this point because you're
chatting. So where a message,
the subject line is so critical
because if it's not good enough,
she's not going to open it in a chat.
The chats open,
you can get a couple lines of texts
before she closes. It goes in and says,
I'm not, I'm not listening to this. A
little bit more margin for error. Exactly.
And I find the chats are
always red, right? If you're
saying is something in chat,
it's always red.
Do not sit around and talk and just
wait for them to respond to everything.
Instead have an interesting story and
it should be your legitimate story and
your life. But everyone has, everyone
has something. And if you don't,
I mean go and talk about your life more,
but find an interesting story in your
life or do something interesting or do
something absolutely go.
If you don't have at least one good story,
you need to get outside mark to go
running naked in the quad. Okay.
So have a short but sweet story prepared,
you know,
a true story about your life and just
dish it. Just start talking. Who cares,
who cares what the other person thinks
right now because they're probably not
going to respond anyway. Right? If you're,
if you're listening and
you care about this,
this is probably because it
hasn't been working. So try this.
So I have to ask and feel free to,
to uh,
to reject this question. But what
was, what was your go to story.
Oh, go to story. Okay. Um,
uh, okay. I think, I think we
may have done something similar.
Um, was it on point? Tactical? Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah. With Kevin Rave.
Yes. So I had recently done this, uh,
urban escape and evasion class that it
sounds like you have taken and are an
expert in which we've done a, an
amateur. I'm like a green belt.
You, you've actually, you've
done more things than I learned.
I learned when I went to him. So he,
he's, he's up up the game and that's,
that's really cool.
I'm going to ask you some questions later,
but I wa I took this,
this course,
urban escape innovations three days
in la. And uh, he, like you mentioned,
I mean he taught me how to
escape out of LAPD handcuffs,
right. Get out of riot flexi cuffs.
Um, you know, my time when I went to,
he did not, we didn't learn about the
newer cars. You remember I'm older cars,
so I was stuck in like a 70,
75 how you name you so that I stole.
Uh, and that was, I mean
the fact that on the,
on the third day of this class, you know,
we got, I got picked up in a van and a,
the, they put a hood over my head. Uh,
strange cause it's Kinda
like the ecofriendly,
the green environmentally friendly type
of like they put like a whole foods bag
over your head.
It was exactly that whole foods bag
over my head so I can see they took my
wallet and flown and drove
around La and I had to get out,
escape from the handcuffs and run
around Los Angeles without money.
And I would tell some
tidbits of the story about,
you know how I know this is all in chat,
all in chat. So was like, Hey, what's up?
And then you're like,
let me tell you about the time I
got got out of lap BD handcuffs.
What's the transition? Okay.
Yeah. Good question. No,
I'm like I'm so into the specifics because
when it comes to all of this, sure.
I remained to this day complete like I
three finger monkey fumble all of this
stuff. I'm such a fucking idiot. So I'm
really interested in the specifics. Okay,
sure, sure. So, so I say, Hey, what'd you
do today? That's, that's pretty much it.
That's pretty much how I would start
that conversation. What did you do today?
Not, what do you do? No, no one cares.
This is not, it's not an interview.
Right? What did you do
today? Uh, if you know,
she's either going to say something
interesting and you can add on that or,
or you are too afraid to comment on
what she said or she's not saying much
saying went to work, right.
Went to school. Uh, you
know, did nothing. Watch him.
Not much. Lol, winky face. Hello.
I tried that. That didn't work
well when I answered that.
So, okay, so you ask what do you
mean when did you do today? Um,
you're saying, you know,
she's saying something, just
saying something often it's,
it's irrelevant. Often it's the same
thing that everyone else says, righty?
As a guy, you're also receiving a lot
of the same thing too. Um, so as a girl,
you know, if you really care, then also,
you know, pay attention to be different,
be different if you can be,
and you know,
interesting because you probably are,
so show that,
so what did you do today? And then
maybe they'll ask what did you do?
And if they don't, it doesn't
matter. You can still say,
because at this point that she didn't
ask, she is not interested. She only,
when she's already not interested,
it can only go up from here. Right.
There's the only upside. Exactly.
And if she asks them, she asked,
so answer and I said, you know, oh,
well just recently this happened. Um,
and if it's six months ago,
fib say just recently this happened and,
and that's,
that's the transition. Got It.
Last weekend or, yeah. You know,
I've just been going over this crazy
class that I took. Cool. Definitely. And,
and talk a little bit, right.
He will do more talking, um,
offer some something interesting. So
we've never talked about this, but I, I,
I will ask anyway,
uh,
the jump to in real life IRL quick.
All right, quick, quick. Tell me more.
Every time I, and how do you and what's,
what's the verbiage? What's,
what's the transition?
So every time I would have like emails,
messages go back and forth,
it would be great because the
emails you actually get, you know,
you get good information back and if
you're doing back and forth emails,
you're actually communicating a lot.
And a lot of people are, um, uh,
I mean I think it's not so much anymore.
Right. I started, you know, I was,
I did online dating maybe three times
in my life and, um, it was all great.
I like it actually was successful
every time. And then glad,
I'm glad I always did it. And back then,
I mean, when I first started I was 18,
I'm 29 now,
so it 11 years ago and uh,
people were more fearful of meeting
someone on the Internet. Right. Uh,
that was a little different. It
was different back then. Right.
You didn't use her full name as long
until Facebook came out that people use
their full name because they had to,
but you didn't want to miss out on this
social network. I mean, I didn't, uh,
so I'm sorry, what was the question?
The jump to in real life,
the jump to IRL I, okay.
So what I learned was messaging back and
forth was comfortable and it actually
made it more difficult to
jump into a meeting on chat.
You've quickly communicated if
you had an interesting story,
you've quickly communicated that you have
interesting things to talk about, your,
you know,
confident enough to talk about it.
At least if you have other stories like
this, you're probably interesting person.
I mean, you're, you're probably
already are an interesting person. Um,
and after about five minutes and don't,
don't linger,
don't wait until the
conversation dies down. Um,
there's a Seinfeld episode
where I think George,
because sands found that it was best
when he left at the top and the heights,
I'll just like the rocky Marciano
approach to dating. He's like, all right,
that was my best joke and I
got to go out actually. Right,
because you let it linger,
then it's this boring.
Here's remembering though how it
ended. Well make it good, right?
He just had this awesome story, you
know, the edge of her seat and he's like,
oh wow. That's like, that's really cool.
It's really interesting. It's like, Hey,
you know, I have to run, I have to
go do some other interesting thing.
I've your rescues, I'm getting this
down the street from some penguins.
And uh, from there you say, you
know, I have to run right now. Um,
you know,
get some information because you don't
want to meet someone just because they
said lol smiley face. Right. You also,
they need to feel like they've favor in
that value as well. Like no one wants to,
I don't like it when someone comes up and
just offers me a bunch of stuff for no
reason. Like, what do you want from me?
Right? Right. You want something from me.
So that's just trying to think in their
position and try to put yourself like
reverse the role and what would
happen if that happened to you. Um,
so I conversation a little
bit more, try to, you know,
learn some interesting things about them.
Ask them questions that are not common
and you can learn some questions from the
emails, right? If you,
if you create a fake profile and
another state don't respond to people,
I think that's deceptive. Just
let emails come in, right?
And see what people say and learn from
those because you'll see the sand,
the common questions,
the questions that you think are really
unique that everyone else is asking.
Don't ever ask those.
Um,
you'll learn those overtime instead tried
to think of something different. Um,
and I didn't, I thought I was being
unique, but I was asking him the same.
Are there any unique questions that you
relied on consistently? Uh, I mean, you,
you, I would say I would
just ask about the thing,
things that I actually wanted to
know. Like, I want you to know,
would you rather lose your front
teeth or cut off your thumbs?
Would you ask them questions like that?
I'm just kidding.
That's a dude. One type
question I'd probably not
appropriate for online dating.
Um, no. I just asked her like, how's
your day? Not, not what did you do today?
Or like, what was the most, I mean, uh,
implore them to give you the
interesting information about your life,
about their life.
What is the most interesting thing that
happened to you in the last week? Yeah.
And now they're going to
recall and re feel like,
have the same emotions that they felt
at that most interesting time of their
life in the last week. Yeah. Got It.
So I have to go to do this other
interesting thing and then what? Uh,
so I have to go, I have
to go and do x, um,
make a joke if he can have to go save
something wins. That's funny. Right?
I think that's funny. Um,
maybe it's not ab test that.
Um, but you know, let's, let's grab a
quick coffee this week. Uh, you know,
I did dinners a few times
and I quickly ran it,
ran into having a dinners with a bunch
of people I really didn't want to have
dinner with. Yeah. It's a one to three
hour plus commitment. Yeah. Yeah.
So then it's coffee, it's coffee, it's
easy. No, it's easy to, easy to leave.
It's quick. You don't,
you don't have to, uh,
it's not a big deal if you pay for it,
right?
You're not setting any stage or anything.
You can pay for it and be nice and it's
not a big, you know, it's not a big event.
What, uh, if, if those,
some people listening to this and
we'll certainly of the male variety,
um, but not definitely. Hello ladies.
I know you're listening to you,
but just try to go out and hit on guys
for a day and you will see how brutal
that side of the game is.
It's fucking terrible. Uh,
let's just assume that there are
guys listening to this. Maybe women,
it could be either and they're
saying, you know, I need a Sammy.
I need someone to help me automate this,
to swipe right on all these profiles to
automatically like all these people to
simplify this process because dating
online seems to be a sort of high volume,
low yield proposition. I
want to stack the deck. Uh,
how would they find someone to help?
What would they look for?
Ask for it.
Sure, sure. I mean, I don't know
of any because I haven't used any,
but I would look specifically for
dating services that use analytics. Um,
if you like to play with this kind
of stuff, if you'd like to, you know,
if you'd like to be analytical or if
you'd like to see how you can stack the
deck yourself. I think playing
cards is interesting. Uh,
use existing dating services like Okcupid
or match and Hay for their pay for
their additional software
there, there, there,
there are a premium
service premium services.
Or now if you wanted to find, say
a freelancer, a programmer, a,
what are the qualifications that someone
would look for if you're like, okay,
I want you to write a script to say,
hypothetically if I,
if I live in Chicago,
I want to auto like everyone in Chicago
who fits the following specifications,
but I don't know how to do that
because I'm not a techie. Uh,
who would I look to hire?
Like if I went to elance or one of the,
one of these sites,
uh,
what would my sort of project request?
Like, uh, I mean there's
two things I'll say to that.
The first thing I'll get quickly
out of the way. Uh, you, it's,
that always seems like the best
idea and that's what I want to do.
I want to get as many people. I wanted
to cast the widest net as possible.
And until you do it, you think of the
great idea and I would tell you to not to,
but you're going to so ah,
do it.
Learn that you're then spending all your
time with people you don't care about.
Right? So then you actually
have to spend time filtering.
And I spent the next half of my, that time
filtering. But to answer your question,
because I understand, like if someone
told me not to, I still would.
So to get that knee, now
you have to sometimes. Um,
I would look for somebody a go on,
Ilana said, go on Craig's list.
I would try to find someone who's
developed software who can develop web
crawlers,
um,
who can develop backend web software
and who can develop may, you know,
maybe basic analytic software you don't
need. They don't need to be a genius.
This is, this is very simple stuff
that you're doing PR programmatically.
Got It. Uh, if you are using,
do you, I don't even, uh,
if you were on Tinder,
hypothetically or otherwise,
uh,
does any of the advice change?
Um, you know, I don't yet. I don't
use Tinder. I'm not on Facebook,
but if I were to use Tinder,
uh, what would I do? Let's see.
Well, I mean lately I've been playing
around with computers and algorithms.
A computer vision that lets you
actually see a, you know, let's,
you may make a computer
actually see things and
interpret things. But on Tinder,
I mean,
you could have the computer decide
hot or not for you after putting,
adding in some inputs. I think
you could, you could do some,
I guess yes, the answer is yes,
you can do some basic things there.
Um, but I think what I'd want to do is
does Tinder have descriptions of people?
I'm not sure. Very short
description sort of descriptions.
So the thing you want is a Dataset,
right?
You want to know who are the people
and maybe you have, you know,
maybe have girlfriends who are on Tinder,
like look them up,
look up their information,
look up anything that would help provide
information to people who you think you
would like to date and people who you
would think you would not like to date
because you need to be able to
have, uh, information on both.
So you can write some sort of algorithm.
Um,
because Tinder has such little
information, I would say, you know,
for a friend I wrote actually a Tinder
script that would essentially swipe until
I saw that video. And that video
was just, it was hilarious.
So if you want to just swipe,
you can use a record
player and a one of those
iPhone nubs to swipe for you.
Um, but then after that it's,
I believe it's chatting. Is that
right? Yeah, it's all chatting. Okay.
So most applications on
mobile, a iPhone, android,
they're actually web based.
So you're actually dealing with a lot of
the same web software or web protocols.
So if you wanted to automate some of that,
man,
I guess what I would personally
do if I were on there,
I would create or hire someone
to create a Bot that would
swipe yes swipe correctly. Yes, I
want to communicate with this person.
And when we were matched up then I would
have it automatically communicate and
then I would have it texted
me and I could probably,
what I might do is actually automate a
few like have a story or two that I could
text back to this device. Uh, wherever I,
wherever I was like that was not as if
I was on a date. If I were on a date,
I will be able to text back and say,
turn this story on it.
We just communicate with something.
Right. Go on, go on time to go.
But you would still see the messages
so you could still actually communicate
with that person live from
your phone. Right, right.
You might not be or I guess you could
open the APP at that point. But yes,
I would again find the same
type of person, someone who
can create web software,
not just a website but a web crawler.
I think that's the,
that's the differentiation. Someone who
knows how to sort of crawl an automate,
right. Produce something that's atonomous
that can communicate with this website.
With this app,
how would you vet the people who respond?
So if you go to say craigslist or,
uh,
an Odesk or elance and you put up looking
for web crawler specialist for dating
project you described roughly
we were trying to accomplish.
So you get 37 responses from people
who are saying, I can do this. Yeah,
no problem.
Is there something that you could have
them do as a test to assess their yeah,
competency? Um, I would ask them,
I'd find a website that you like,
maybe,
you know,
a news website or something and I would
something that has other content on it.
And I would say, write me a script
or don't write me a script. You know,
if you can do this quickly,
I will hire you.
Please have it go to every
news article for the last week,
right? It's something that
has to hit click back, right.
And take these elements of the page,
take the, the sub, the headline,
um, and take the fifth word. Okay.
And put those in an XML document,
something that clearly is not that
valuable, may make it not valuable. Right?
You don't want them to work too hard.
You don't want to abuse their time and
you don't want to suck the value from
them. Right. If someone, I would not
want to do free work for someone,
but if it's a test that they
clearly get no value out of,
I'm more likely to do that.
So I'd say it's something
that you can't actually use.
It doesn't have any interesting.
That's interesting.
So it's not even a time issue. It's
really a utility question. Yeah.
I feel like if someone, you know,
if I'm working with someone, right,
if I were asking for something
that gave me a real ROI,
you'd be less inclined to
do it. But from saying, Hey,
this is just a test of your competency,
you know, I can't use the output. Yeah.
I'm happy to. I'm happy to
demonstrate that of my capabilities.
I'm not happy to provide free services.
Free,
right value and in exchange for nothing.
Correct.
Yeah. Huh. That's really interesting.
I never thought about that before. Uh,
very cool. So, uh, two things. I think
we should definitely talk about my space.
Okay. And it looks like we've,
we've temporarily run out of wine,
so I'm going to pause this for just
one moment and we shall be back.
Don't go away.
We are back after a bathroom break
and an alcohol refill with Sammy.
Sammy, how the hell are
you? I'm great. And Hey,
I promised the fine people at home
that we talk about my space and, uh,
so I don't even know where,
how to introduce this story.
Tell me a little bit about
your involvement with my space.
Okay. So my involvement,
I was a user of my space.
Um, so back in the day, this was, this
was probably, this was 10 years ago,
so I was 19 at the time. Uh, and my space,
there's 2005 my space was the
number one site on the internet,
number one of Google above anything else.
And I thought this was interesting.
This is kind of cool. Um, all
of my friends used it pretty
much everyone, you know.
Yeah. Pretty much all my friends
used it and I hadn't used it yet. Um,
and I thought, okay, you know, everyone's
using it. I should get on here.
Just see like, see what it's about. Right.
A little social proof and to check it out.
And I created in my space,
added a couple of friends, made a
profile. It was like, this is Kinda cool.
And I'd like a started uploading photos.
I finally had a digital camera and
I took a bunch of random photos,
my friends and would post them.
And once I uploaded the 12th photo
and I tried to upload the 13th,
it said, you've hit our limit
now, today, today. That's insane.
That's insanity. If a website
told you if Instagram said, oh,
12 photos, you've hit our Max,
huge, no one would use it. Yeah,
he'd be gone. Right. But back then,
it wasn't, it wasn't relevant. Uh,
not that many people had that many photos.
I mean,
digital cameras were
getting cheaper and um,
but for the most part that wasn't an
issue and I thought it was an issue.
So I said, okay, well how do I get around
this? I don't like having 12 photos.
I want, I want 14. I think
that's, that's a solid number.
Um,
and I found a way to upload a 13th photo,
so I uploaded it to 13th and it wasn't
a big deal. It's just I wanted to,
I didn't like the limitation.
Um, so I went around it and uh,
on the front page you have, um, you
know, sort of description of yourself,
like your bio, your
relationship status, uh,
your favorite books and stuff.
And I thought, okay, we'll
be cool to, to change. Um,
there's the relationship status.
And uh,
I was dating someone and so I had in a
relationship and that was a dropdown.
You can choose from like single,
divorced, married, et cetera.
And I thought it'd be funny if I could
change that to in a hot relationship,
subtle change. But if someone
saw it, that'd be funny. Um,
they might think it's interesting
or funny. Uh, at least I do.
And they wouldn't let me do that.
So I thought,
I wonder how it could get around this.
So I played around on the website,
you know. How old were you at
the toast? I was 19, 19. Um,
as though my sec second year of my
company. So it's working fulltime,
uh, in La. What did your
company do? My company, uh,
did and still does a phone system.
So cloud-based,
actually now it's cloud
based phone systems, but we
sorta voiceover Ip company,
uh, called finality about, wow. 11,
12 years ago now.
That's up 700 Internet years ago.
That was so many internet years
and calves ago. So you were 19?
Yeah, I was 19 and I would work sort of
night and day. So it actually, you know,
go to work,
go to the office,
come back at night and I'd play around
in the smiley face site because that was
the cool thing at the time.
That was the hip thing.
So I was messing around on the site and
I finally found a way that I execute
javascript. And javascript is
a web coding language and um,
javascript allowed me to modify the page.
So my space never allowed
you to answer javascript,
but I found a vulnerability within the
myspace filters and within web browsers
that allowed me to inject javascript and
it's allowed me to just modify the page
more than you'd be able to. Um,
unfortunately my space gave a lot of, uh,
creative freedom, uh, back then.
So you could actually make the page look
really ugly butt and not do things like
change the relationship
status like I wanted.
So once I figured out I could do this,
I actually realized this,
this exploit I found is
actually extremely powerful.
I can actually do a lot more.
I can make the user do virtually
anything in the web browser. Uh,
without their consent. I could, I
could in fact steal their bank details.
I had no interest in their bank details,
but I could take their pink, you know,
their bank details and have a
bunch of peoples bank information.
So what I found was that whenever
someone visits my profile,
I could make it say in hot relationship.
And I was like, that's cool.
What else can I do?
And I played around further and further.
And finally I realized,
well, I can actually, since
I can control their browser,
I can make them add me as a friend.
It's kind of funny.
So someone visits my profile and they're
not yet my friend, they just add me.
So yeah, that's, you know, it's just
cute and just playing around on here.
It's a social network.
Um, and I thought, well,
the next day I had like one new friend.
I was like, wow, that's not that cool.
Like what else can I do? And there's
different, there's different sections.
For example, your favorite
books, movies, TV heroes.
And I thought it'd be funny
if I added something. Uh,
and there's this hero section. Most
people didn't use it, but some people did.
And you could list your favorite heroes.
So someone who might have like, you know,
uh,
Buddha and Tim Ferris,
some people might not,
I'm not sure.
So I found a way that when
someone would visit my profile,
not only would they add me as a friend,
but they would add me as a hero and it
wouldn't delete their existing heroes.
So if their heroes said, you know, my
mom, my dad and my grandma and say,
I mean it would add it with
a pen to the end. My Mom,
my dad and grandma. But most
of all, Sammy isn't a hero.
They would append that to their hero
section. That was kind of funny. You know,
this would happen to a couple people,
you know,
show off to my nerd friends and
we'd get a laugh and that was that.
And the next day,
you know,
I had so few friends on there that one
person had hit it and one person had this
and it's like, man, how do I
make this go a little faster?
I just want to show a few friends
like, Hey, I made 10 people say this,
I'm on their profile. So I thought, okay,
well if I could make someone added me as
a friend and I can make them add me as
a hero.
Well the codes on my profile,
I could probably make them add
the code to their profile. So Tim,
if he visited my profile, you add me
as a friend and I know he's a hero,
but you'd also had to code
to your profile. If then
someone visited your profile,
they would add me as a friend,
added me as a hero and also the
code would go onto their profile.
So it became a worm.
I believe that's like the
technical definition of a
worm or a virus and it's not
a big, our worms and viruses different.
Ah, man, that's a good question.
I'm not sure what the
technical difference is. Um,
I think usually when they're,
when they're referred to,
at least online that I see,
you know, viruses or buyer,
I are usually referred to when they're
kind of malicious and destructive and
worms or they just spread really quickly
and not necessarily with malicious
intent, not necessarily with malicious
intent, but I guess there aren't too many,
too many things out there that's
spread without malicious intent.
Not to interrupt though. So, so,
all right. So you're like, Hey,
let me make this move a little faster.
Yeah.
So I made it move a little faster
and I figured, okay, in a month,
maybe I'll have like 50,
50 new friends and heroes and someone will
complain rights as someone unintended,
we'll hit it and complain and
they'll my sniffles, we'll remove it.
Sounds not like a big deal.
And I put it up, I put this,
this worm on my,
on my profile,
and I woke up and thought I'd have
like probably four new friends. Um,
and I had 200 and I said,
oh shit.
And I would, an hour later I had
another 200 and I said, oh no,
because after eight hours it was
200 but it was exponential. So it's,
at first I thought it was,
oh,
like going to be a thousand in a
day after I saw the 200 but now it's
exponential. An hour later I
had another 400 an hour later,
another 800 these are people who have a
add me as a friend and then be at same.
He's my hero to their profile.
And then the worms spreads to them
and you know, it, it wasn't malicious,
right? There was no malicious intent.
It's clearly a prank gone wrong. Uh,
and I didn't know what to do.
So immediately I emailed my space
anonymously and I said, hey,
something weird just having it in
my profile. Someone just added me.
Their name is Sammy and
it says same as my hero.
And I found this weird piece of code
that's on my profile and it seems to do
this detailed explanation of exactly what
this crazy big piece of code is doing.
I'm no professional,
but here's my
slice of code appears to be doing the
following 17 things I tend see, yeah,
if I had to make an assumption
about this off, he skated
piece of worm,
um,
and I think you can fix it most easily
and efficiently by doing this one simple
change.
This is what I'd suggest.
One simple change to
stop it in its tracks.
I don't know if it ever got to anyone.
I have no idea to this day. Um,
an hour later went by,
it doubled.
And I figured at some point
it's going to stop, right?
At some point you're going to hit your,
you know,
you're going to hit a maximum because
there are only so many people on my space,
right, right. You can't get it twice.
You can't get the cold twice
at the same time. Right.
So you're going to hit a max
and that's going to be that.
So at about a thousand hours,
I think it was gonna Max out
and I get to work and it's 2000,
and I'm just refreshing.
And I'm like, man, okay,
I should at least deep delete
my profile. It was like, man,
I should delete the worm. So I immediately
delete the word, but like a cold,
you might be cured, but you
spread it. It doesn't matter.
All these other people don't have
it and you can't stop that. Um,
for a moment I thought,
okay,
maybe I should like red another worm that
then go transmits to all these people
and then deletes the first one.
I thought I shouldn't write to worms.
And like a 24 hour period. That's another,
I don't think that's a good idea. Uh,
so I just kind of waited around and I,
I did send that an anonymous email.
I tried to get it to stop.
There's nothing, not much I
could do at that point. Uh,
I did, oh wait, wait more, you know,
jumped to 2000 and then 4,000 and 8,000
it's now there's 8,000 people that says,
Sam,
he is my hero on their profile and now
I'm getting messages from people because
they're deleting me. They're like, Oh,
who's this Sammy Guy who's on my profile?
So the delete me, which when you
delete a profile in my space,
it immediately takes you back to
your profile where the code is,
which reextend every adds me
there must have loved that.
And that was an accident. But I mean
in software you call it by, you know,
a feature when you,
when you have a nice accident like
that so you can't delete it really.
And it's spreading further and further
and further. And I don't know what to do.
Just a 19 year old kid trying
to build some software,
the voip company and voiceover Ip.
And uh,
they just kept going and I
decided, okay, I'm going to have,
I called my girlfriend at the time. I
said, hey, let's have lunch. It's like,
what's wrong? I was like,
I just want to see you.
So we had lunch and I said that, I don't
know what's going to happen, but, um,
this worm thing happened on my space
and it's been growing pretty quick.
Um,
and also there's this company called Fox
that had purchased my space maybe two
months prior for over half
a billion dollars. Um,
so I don't know what's going to
happen. I don't know if, you know,
Mr Murdoch was very happy about
this, uh, in his brand new company.
So I had lunch with my girlfriend and
went back to work and now it's probably
40,000 people, 40,000 people infected
with this, and I'm just like, my space,
please stop. So I'm like, okay, at least
let me delete my profile. So I just,
picture has gone and I deleted.
And it says,
are you sure you wanted to leave
profiles? Like, yes. It's like,
are you absolutely sure you cannot
undo this? I was like, yes. Like, okay,
we are deleting your profile in 24
hours and watch how all these people are
still the profile still fully up.
I can't do anything about it.
It's locked now and online. I say, okay,
I just have to wait it out.
Literally waited out. So by
just sit through the day,
I can't really do much,
can't really think clearly and by uh,
by the time work is done I'm like,
it's probably time to go home. I have,
I don't know,
half a million followers on my
space now that all say same.
He's my hero man.
I go home and before I go home,
like it's probably my last meal.
So I go to AAA, have a Burrito,
it's could be my last like delicious
dinner and I drive home and I drive home.
I opened the browser 900,000 and like,
oh my God,
I didn't even know there were this many
people on my space. This is insane.
This point,
our refresh.
And now I'm just purely interested
in how quickly is it growing.
So now refreshing every second. It was
like, I'll take a snapshot every second,
but browsers in load that fast back then.
So I take a snapshot every three seconds
and it was going two or 3000 people per
second that fast. I mean,
it was insanity. Uh,
and it hit a million. I took
a screenshot, just say, okay,
cool. Still scared. Don't know what
to do. I have nothing to do. I mean,
there's no way to stop this.
I made it.
I made a horrible mistake where I created
a monster. I have great imposter. Yes.
And at about a million, you know, 50,000.
I refresh my profile and says, this
profile has been taken down and I say,
Hallelujah, it's guys down. They took
it down. Thank you. And uh, I was like,
I wonder what happened to the profiles
that also said, Sam, he's my hero.
I wonder if they removed it.
So I go to another profile says this
profile has been taken down temporarily.
Oh No,
it's,
I go to myspace.com the site is down,
the whole team here is here working on it.
That's what it said,
the number one website
on the Internet in 2005.
And I felt bad. I felt, I
felt awful because, hey,
I know what it's like to have a website,
a company that's down.
I know what that's like.
It's awful.
It's an awful feeling and emotion that
I would never want to put onto someone
else. And I had done that inadvertently.
Um, so immediately I'm like,
I need to bring coffee and donuts to
these people because they're in la.
I'm in La. I'm like, maybe I
shouldn't go there and just start,
maybe we shouldn't go there right now.
Um,
I don't know if security is going
to tackle me or what, but I can't.
So I just sat around and a day went by and
a week went by, I thought, okay, I have,
I have two options. Maybe
I can, you know, uh, I,
I mean I can talk about this or not
and I didn't really say much about it.
And someone emailed me and said, hey,
I saw this thing on my space, this is,
did you make this?
And I couldn't really hide because hey,
I wasn't trying to be anonymous. It was
a prank. They gone horribly wrong. And,
uh, I said, sure.
And I did a little interview and I did
an interview for a couple of different
web thing, you know, little
websites and someone was like, Hey,
you want to do the interview for,
for our site? And it's like, sure.
Like who's it for? And they're like
wired. And I'm like, Oh, uh, I dunno.
And I heard that you guys have
heard of you guys. Yeah. And it,
I never heard from my space.
Um,
and a week went by and two weeks went
by and someone asked, hey, you know,
people are selling shirts that say same.
He's my hero.
I like, that is awesome. And like, you
know, you making money off that like, no,
but that's okay.
A good in my book.
And a month goes by, two months,
three months go by and I'm, you know,
I'm, I'm pretty stoked. Um, you know,
I'd be comfortable in free and the free,
I'm feeling great. Like
never doing that again. Uh,
and a six months go by and I said,
you know,
I just bought a new car
and company's doing well.
And at this point I,
I walked down to my car,
I'm gonna drive to work today
and six months later from them,
from the worm and as you guys standing
next to my car and I'm like, oh no,
I'm getting carjacked.
And I walk up to them and they're like,
Sammy the same, my name Sammy. And I
said, no, carjackers only now your name
and two guys behind. Very
well educated. Carjack yeah,
no, it's all on my license plate.
And two other guys come up behind me.
Let me see Sammy, we have
a, we have a search warrant
for you. And was like, what?
And they all show me badges and
one shows me secret service.
One shows me electronics crimes
task force and other shows. Me, uh,
district attorney La Da,
uh, another shows me,
it was LAPD is a,
we have a search warrant and
I don't know anything about,
I don't know why they think the law,
anything about law or search warrant.
I'm a high school dropout. Right. I
served maybe one year in high school,
served like a prison
sentence. I did, I did,
but a bunch of homework and
did some of the tests and
they said, we have the search warrant
and I just, he don't like what can I do?
What can I do? And I recalled an
episode of 24 where they said,
show me the search warrants. So I
said, show me the search warrant.
I don't know if that actually applies
and law or if it was like CGI.
Excuse me. They're like,
wait, what? Oh, okay.
It's upstairs. I was like, oh, okay.
And they started talking to me and they
didn't mention any specifics and I was
hoping it was,
my space actually had points.
So he was a hacker. You play around,
you know, you play around anything,
you go through different things that
maybe you're not supposed to go into.
Never malicious,
never like causing harm,
but you want to see what you can
get into. It's a puzzle. It's a,
an real world applicable puzzle.
Um, what you can break into.
And after about half an hour,
I'm like, guys, you know,
do your search and not going to obstruct.
Just show me the search warrant and
do your thing. Um, so we go upstairs,
these four guys and me and uh,
we walk up to my place and my girlfriends
in it wrapped in a sheet crying and my
roommate is in your
apartment? My apartment? Yeah,
man apartment at the time in the,
in the Marina del Rey and my,
my roommates. Good friend of mine,
like naked, weeping girlfriend.
Good start. And my roommate,
he's an a bath towel.
But what is going on here and verse?
I suspect it's something,
but other than that,
she's, she's, you know,
she was in bed in my room and he was in
the shower getting ready for work when a
dozen agents busted into my
apartment that I had not known.
So while I was going down,
while you were done with the car,
they were already going into the
apartment while I was downstairs.
Unbeknownst to me, they were in my
apartment going through everything
and they finally handed me the search
warrant and I read through it and they
finally mentioned something of
my space and I was like, okay,
it's my space related obviously.
Uh, and after that there,
they just went through
everything and from, you know,
my roommates and girlfriends respected
to date, just came in with guns.
It finally, finally something
in the movie hackers was a real,
like a dozen agents busting
into your place to, you know,
get a computer crime guy with a bunch
of, you know, s semiautomatic weapons.
And, uh, I watch it, what am,
what am I going to do with
like a DVD, like note aid,
I'm not sure.
But they had the search warrant and it
said they could pretty much take anything
that had data on it. So they went through
my, they took my computer, my laptop,
my iPod, my x box, any cds, DVDs,
and sat me down and I'm reading the
search warrant further and further.
And finally it comes to this part
and it says they can search my body,
my car, my, my home. And this other
address, like what's this address?
Oh No, my company, and at this point is,
is two years in, probably had 30
employees and investors, we hit,
there's a legitimate company,
a legitimate tech startup that company's
depended on for their phone service lot,
the, a decent number of companies
dependent on us. And I was like,
you guys are going to my company. And
they're like, no, we're already there.
Now, I never, I never
knew this, but you know,
I heard this second hand from 20 people,
but simultaneously and other dozen
agents went to my company and said,
who runs this place? And Chris,
the CEO came out and he said, uh,
and they said, what does Sammy Kamkar
have access to? And he said, well, yeah,
he's cofounder, I mean everything. And
the guy looks back to another agent, says,
all right guys, take.
And I'm like, no. Right.
I don't know what Chris did, but
he, I don't know what he did,
but for two hours he somehow,
and Chris is,
I mean he like mentored me for
years and I mean the Chris Lyman,
this guy's awesome and uh,
taught me so much about are not the
droids you're looking for her. Yeah.
I don't know what magic he
is because I didn't have any,
but he got them to ultimately not
take the server room and turned down
essentially all these companies that are
depending on a phone system for their
company that are, uh,
you know, call centers.
They didn't take down all of these
companies call centers. Instead,
they just took my computer and
my phone and put everyone in a,
put. Everyone in the conference room
had guns out and said, you know,
he'd get off that
keyboard. Terrifying. Yeah.
A friend of mine who was his first day.
It was that his,
one of my best friends is actually,
I didn't, I met him online. Well,
like we met online and it like a form
or something and he emailed me and what
did you do today?
What did you do?
That's the most interesting thing
is let me tell you a story. Um,
and I said,
I actually,
I convinced him to leave his job in Denver
and he came out with a u haul to come
work at my company. And I said, hey,
while you're, while you're, uh, you know,
come stay at my place.
So I was actually crashing at my place.
He didn't run to the secret service
because we had in my apartment complex,
we had to, uh, to play two garages,
one for guests and one for residence.
So I went to the residence where they
were waiting, he went to the guests,
drove to work, didn't know anyone.
It was his first day. It was Monday.
So he goes to like shake his
hand to someone and she's like,
hand off the mouse and keyboard.
Go in the conference room.
Secret Service and he's like,
what he is as you haul out the
back format with all this crap,
all his crap,
he just quit his job,
drove out from Denver to this company,
you know that he met me once. It's
like JT, Marlin and associates.
I hear this boiler room
here, this, you know,
later on because he's like not
talking to me for a little bit.
Come down to this company that he
thinks is getting shut down here.
No one has any idea why a dozen
agents are at their company. Nobody.
They just know that my name was said
they took my computer and they left, um,
poor guy.
So he didn't know what the thing I
explained to Terry wine and it was like,
oh yeah, that's weird. That's
funny. But unexpected. And,
uh, I, so they took my computer.
Worst part was the Dick my iPod.
That was probably the worst because all
my music was on my computer and my iPod
and it's just really hard
to get music back then.
So I then got a lawyer and you know,
for six months I fought with the DA
and, uh, I, you know, I was, pardon me.
It was like, well, you know, I,
I think it was a bit much, right? I did,
I did something wrong and this is
no doubt about that. I, you know,
I wouldn't do that. I wouldn't do that
again. And uh, but they were being,
it was very harsh.
I felt it was very harsh and what they
were trying to do was to take away my
computer use for the rest of my life
for the rest of your life in my life.
So again, I didn't have a
high school diploma. Uh, I,
you know, I help my mom, like
I send money to my mom. Uh,
you know, I moved out when I was
15 and I think, you know, I've,
I've foraged emancipation
documents so I could actually live,
live by myself and sign up,
get a cell phone in her apartment,
and I had just to support myself and
help support her a little. And, uh,
so I couldn't do anything.
Like, if I conduct computers,
I don't know what I'd do.
I'd have to, I dunno,
finished high school.
I just got an imagine that in
this day and age also, I mean,
just with the exponential
growth of these technologies,
it's like how can you possibly
avoid touching a computer?
I mean,
you wouldn't,
you would have to just go into a
live in Pennsylvania with the Amish.
Yeah, yeah. Um, so they,
they were trying to take away your
access to computers for this year of your
natural life.
Uh,
I mean at first it was like they were
talking about prison and all of these
things. I don't know if they're scaring
me or what, but, um, ultimately, you know,
I had a choice I'd do to,
I could like spend a lot of time and a
lot more money fighting it. You know,
he'd spent all my savings. It was 19 to
to fight this and get a good lawyer. And,
uh,
ultimately we were able to come to an
arrangement and that was an agreement
where I would not be able to use computers
for the rest of my life. However,
I would go on Bay probation and I would
visit her probation officer once a week.
And if I were on good behavior, I would
be able to get that reduced and again,
be able to get her potentially
even removed. And it was really,
it was within reason.
It was like if I don't commit any
crimes or releasing any other worms,
then I would be able to get that
removed. After a few years, it was like,
okay,
that's reasonable.
I could focus on my company right now.
I had at that point,
it was bigger.
It was another six months later.
And I had a team and I could communicate
with my team every day and I could
actually work without necessarily using
the internet and doing that much, uh,
on the Internet and, um,
you know, computers, um,
and just manage right.
And that point I kind of just
manage and I took it, uh,
that agreement. And after three years
I went back to court and I said, Hey,
my probation officer loves me.
I paid all my restitution.
I've done my 720 hours of community
service picking up trash. Uh,
and because of some, you know,
they didn't document it properly,
so I did another extra few hours.
You're welcome.
Like 800 hour go slam.
That's all. I was like,
wait, what? Oh Man. All this time.
5:00 AM every Saturday. You know, it
means, I didn't know. It was awful.
It was tough. You have to
wear an orange jumpsuit. Yes,
it was. I would, I would
park, I would park my car,
put it in an orange jumpsuit at 6:00
AM and then walk to the waist refuse
management facility. Um, I made
friends with the guys who ran it there.
They were actually pretty cool.
And I would, because they liked me,
they would let me go on the trash runs
where we would drive around Santa Monica.
And that means we've got to say that,
see the ocean a lot and driving,
driving a dump truck,
basically picking up trash. Uh,
you think I'd be able to like
help more effectively. You know,
I'd be happy to help in other ways. But
uh, that was the task lead before you.
Yeah. So you did your community
service, your restitution.
So after three years I went back to court,
I went back to court and uh, you know,
I said I'm a model computer not
touching the citizen and uh,
I would love to get,
get some of that access back and you know,
we got everything removed and uh,
I was able to touch computers again,
just kind of randomly one
day everything came back.
I could touch computers, I wasn't
a felon, I had no more probation,
I had no more community service.
Now what was it like after three
years in technological time
to
get back up to speed?
I was probably 22 or 23
at this point and I was,
I think a is really cool because
it was very fortunate. Um,
the thing that I had exploited,
the thing that I had exploited when I
wrote the worm was something called Ajax
or some term called web 2.0.
And I don't know if you remember,
but this was right when Google maps
came out before we had mapquest.
And what would happen on mapquest? You'd
go somewhere, he'd make directions.
And if you want to like zoom out,
you click a button and you'd,
it would refresh the page.
You had to click the plus or the minus
actually huge pain in the ass and the
page would refresh. And like if you want
to go right, you couldn't scroll right,
you'd hit it right. What
does Ajax asynchronous helped
me out here? No, leave.
It's asynchronous Java's giants,
Aix, Aix, Armani exchange.
I believe that's camex art rx.
Sorry. It's American Express.
Um,
so,
so were you able to catch up quickly
after that? Well, so, so the, the,
the warm that I wrote
actually abused or used Ajax,
because I saw a Google maps came
out and you could scroll your map.
It was amazing. You could scroll, you
didn't have to refresh the page every one,
every time you went to go.
Right.
This was the coolest thing on
the web at that point. Yeah.
And for people listening who may
not be familiar with the term Ajax,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
I've had plenty of wine and which leads
to overconfidence and matters of my
total incompetence. Uh, but Ajax
would be, for instance, where you,
you select from a dropdown,
an item,
let's say if you're buying a domain
name and you're able to see that value
change on the page without
refreshing the page. Exactly.
That'd be a consumer experience
of Ajax, right? Right.
It used to be you have the refresh,
you might hear the click right whenever
that information would get refreshed and
now you can just seamlessly get new
information on your page updating without
you changing pages. Right. Without the
whole thing. Refreshing. Uh, it was,
it was beautiful and I use that so that,
because I could write the worm in a
way that it would refresh the page,
but that's just annoying.
I want to happen in the background.
The user shouldn't be bothered that
there's a virus turning on their computer.
It should just happen, you know,
seamlessly. She'd be very comfortable.
Infiltration.
It's an,
it didn't cause them harm or annoyance,
then a man that clicks annoying. Uh,
so that was Ajax. And by the time
it came back to computers, uh,
this was three years later,
something had come out called drum roll.
The iPhone. Ah, nothing had
changed between then. I mean, for,
for the most part,
the biggest technologies
to hit tech was web 2.02,
three years later I phone.
So I came back,
I was standing in line at of the
grove waiting for the iPhone.
So you really, you really, uh,
in a way threaded the needle.
I mean you really, you, you came,
you exited and then re entered the scene
in such a way that you really didn't
miss a lot of the major
developments. Yeah. I wish I
could say that was by design,
but, well, what is it? I,
if I could be good or lucky, I'll
take lucky. Right. But I will,
I will say this, um, you know,
before then I was, I was, you know,
really introverted.
I was an introverted nerd and I'm still,
I'm still a nerd and I love that.
But those three years,
I wasn't allowed to touch computers.
The thing that I spent my night and day
ever since I was nine years old and got
kicked out of a chat room, um,
that, that changed my life, right?
I had to spend my time doing something
else. So during the day I was working,
but then, you know, that at that
point I was 20. I turned 21.
So I started going out and uh,
then I started going, you know,
making friends and communicating
and socializing. Uh, you know,
I went out and I said, oh, what is that
thing? What's that bright thing? Ah,
oh,
it's a son.
They're going outside and doing all
these outdoors things and I, you know,
learned about what a gym was.
And I did these things because
I had nothing else to do. Right.
The one thing was taken away. I mean,
they took my, they took my Xbox.
That's not cool. I was like, okay, let's,
let's roll with it. Right. And I think
life is good, right? Like life
is good no matter what. I mean,
at least here in the u s I feel
pretty fortunate. So let's, uh,
let's, we have other facilities
available to us, so let's use those now.
Cam Card just for those people wondering.
Ethnic background is Iranian.
So yeah, my mom is from Iran. Um,
my dad is
from Dubai but also Iranian and they
came to the Pittsburgh to study.
They came to view or, um, down
the street, university of Pitt,
Pittsburgh. Uh, I would have suggested
Carnegie Mellon. What were the tech?
Um, and my dad I I
believe was business. Uh,
my mom, I'm not telecommunications,
I think. Got It.
And ultimately, how do they
choose Pittsburgh of all places?
And that's a great question. I have no
idea. What are the unsolved mysteries?
Alright, yeah. Well, one of
these things, I mean, little,
little kept secret about Pittsburgh.
Good sandwiches,
good sandwiches. It's like, Oh,
you haven at Princeton for all those
Princetonians listening. But yeah,
they went to school there
and my dad, uh, you know,
my dad left when I was
younger and uh, yeah, so, so
they're from Iran. I was born like a
year later after they came, came here,
my mom was like probably 20.
Um,
and we kind of young and I
grew up in Pittsburgh. What,
uh,
or say who,
who are some of the people,
whether you met them or not,
who most influenced your trajectory
through life besides your parents?
Um, it's a good question.
Uh, I would say, you know,
it changes over time. Um, I mean I love,
there's so many people out there who've
done amazing things or even just have a
really cool perspective of the
world. So, uh, I tried to, if I can,
if I'm fortunate enough, I tried to glean
some information for people when I can.
I say it started when I really,
you know,
the available information on the
Internet, right? Just Internet itself. Um,
I think it was Al Gore who created
the Internet, sort of hers, you know,
she did a great job. You did a great,
just tighten it up. I mean, I, you know,
I've ever,
everything I,
I've a lot of what have I accomplished
or am learning is big from the Internet,
so thanks to that. But if it were people,
then I would say when I was young,
when I was like 15 or 16, I got my
first contract on the Internet. And,
um, just a friend of mine, someone I met
online who had taught me about business,
um, when my mom told me this
is what the cheats, right,
as the cheat codes. Exactly.
Yeah. So I was writing this counter
strike cheats and someone said, hey,
do you want a job? And this guy, uh,
this guy says Dan, he actually taught
me a lot about business because, uh,
then I needed a job. My mom lost
her job. She said, Sammy, you need,
you're not going to school.
You're just playing games all day.
You need to get a job and help pay rent.
Um, if you're going to live here. I said,
okay. So, uh, I, you know,
I was trying to fill out applications
and Starbucks and Ralph's and um,
someone emailed me named Stan said,
Hey, I saw your cheat code. I,
she'd started cheat software. Do you
want to write software for my company?
We're doing some sort of game development
stuff. I was like, absolutely.
So I contracted with this guy and
met him. He was awesome. And He, uh,
at that point I did a little contract
for him and then I was contract and for
another company and they wanted me to
work full time. And my mom said, well,
if you're gonna work for a company full
time, you know, take, you know, if I,
I was like, mom, what do I do in the
negotiation when they've asked how much,
if they ask how much, and she
was like, just say, you know,
whatever you want to just say, you
know, tell them this low number.
And you know, if they say that's
too much, just accept lower.
And I had lunch with Stan is like,
oh,
so you're going to tell them that you
have a base expectation of 75 k and you
know, when their offer
that you have that's there,
that's what they're offering and
that you're going to get, you know,
the other offer has, uh, you
know, a five year stock grant, uh,
with 5,000 shares and that's
what you want. And you're
like, I like Stan's advice.
I have no idea what you just said.
And that's all bullshit.
And he's like, so, and I'm like,
I don't have another offer and I don't
want to lie. I don't want to be deceptive.
And I'll say that that's like,
you know,
besides fake profiles on
Okcupid the other time,
it's okay to be deceptive as soon during
an interview because they're being
deceptive to you. Probably.
So during your, uh, during
your initial interview, um,
and so I went into this
meeting as a 15 year old kid,
just repeating the lines because
I had no idea what I was doing.
Reading verbatim on the other
offer has a five year stuck dread.
Exactly. Exactly what, say you
had a six month cliff and the five
year vesting period that's like,
I don't know what word salad. Hopefully
that compels you to give me more money.
Stock was, and uh, I,
I thought in my head,
well, the only reason I,
I followed his advice was because
he was a very smart and logical guy.
I really respected him because of that.
Um,
and everything he had told
me and taught me, I mean,
he was pretty much always
correct about things.
And I'm also okay with taking
risks that's acceptable.
Like there's always another
way to do something. Um,
so I followed his advice and I walk,
you know,
and actually I went down for this
meeting and they said, hey, uh,
they had once with me and I took the
Amtrak to go see them in San Diego is a
company that I'd been
working with remotely.
They never met me and I want
to take the Amtrak down.
And it's really like hoping I
got this job, we had dinner.
It was really friendly and just
kind of casual. And that was that.
I was like guy and I felt like it
was weird. It's like a slap the face.
Like we never talked about the job.
We never talked about like,
am I getting this job or are
you guys going to hire me?
I really could use a job.
And I said, so guys, did you want to
talk about like, I don't know, salary?
And I was really timid.
Um,
another reason that not having a Peter
was awesome because I was forced to talk
to people. So they're like, sure,
let's talk. And they're like,
what would you like? Like, and I just
repeated verbatim what he told me,
what he taught me. And it was,
you know, I have, uh, you know,
all my base expectation is 75 k and
another offer for that and another company
in La.
Uh,
it would be better in la because I
already lived there in my head. I'm like,
please let me leave out. Oh,
like not la La, I love La,
but please let me move out of my mom's
place and get my own place if I'm making
75 gag and afford to place, um, and Pan,
handle my problems place right and
cover her. So, and, uh, I have this,
you know, stock grant, whatever,
blah, blah, blah, word garble.
And they looked at each other and
said, okay. And I was flabbergasted.
And so, so what he, I mean,
he taught me a ton of woman
in my early years, right?
That was my first time in a real
job, a full time job. He got me,
he got me a 40 gear, 40 k a
year race. Uh, there just stand.
Who had hired you based on your
cheat codes, correct. Yeah.
So he became a mentor and then for the
next job he was it for is for that job.
He was my mentor.
Like he lived in San Diego,
so I hung out with them all the
time. He was older. He was probably,
so he was helping you negotiate it
against his own company or I guess I was
contracting Pram. I had written
some software for him that was that,
like he didn't need a lot,
so I helped him, you know,
did a little contract and after that we
just remained friends. Scott and Scott,
older guy, scientist. I'm
a doctor, like really,
really, really smart guy. Uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to
mind for you? Hmm. Successful. Okay.
Uh, as lot of sessile people. I mean,
I guess it depends how you
interpret success. Well,
that's, that's up to you. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I'd say, oh, lately
it's like a lot of it's just how,
how can you remain happy,
right?
What can you do to actually increase
your net happiness while reducing the
negative, the negatives in your life and
without hurting people? I think that's,
that's kind of like,
I don't have many morals or ethics.
I have like one pretty strict rule,
which is don't intentionally hurt someone.
Ahimsa.
It's do no harm. It's also the
hippocratic oath. But yeah. Oh No, no.
Do No harm. Intentionally tension
trail of fire,
that's for sure.
But I'm just thinking as long
as it's not intentional, right.
No deliberate harm. It's
not you. It's me. So who,
man, I mean there, there are people
who are like, I think respect and, uh,
I tried to, everyone, I think everyone
I meet has someone to teach me,
has something to teach me.
Uh,
I think Richard Branson is really cool
just because it's like every time I read
about him or learn a little bit about him,
he was like having fun and has,
you know,
he's on an island or on a ship
or like racing across the ocean.
I mean, he's doing awesome
things. Um, he's having fun.
He's not necessarily defining success
for doing things based off what is
expected of you. Right. He's, uh,
he's doing I think what he wants and
that's what I really like. I want to,
you know, that's who I want
to do things that I want,
um, and have fun and
really enjoy my life. Um,
and hope maybe I can contribute
in some ways, but who are, uh,
who are some of the people
who had the biggest influence
on your worldview besides Stan?
Let's just say after Stan [inaudible]
who was heavy on my worldview. Yeah.
Or just way of thinking about life.
Are there other people? Well, let's,
let's take it even more
granular. Uh, in the world of,
and this is a term that's become
unfortunately very overused,
but in the world of hackers,
right?
People were finding non
obvious solutions to problems.
Uh,
is there anyone who had a particularly
large influence on you? Uh, in the,
in the world of hackers?
I mean,
Kevin Mitnick was kind of the
biggest well known hacker. Sure.
So I've always followed him.
The Art of deception. Yeah.
So scarred made of lock
picks. So amazing. Um,
but if I had to,
if I had to give specific people
that I think are awesome, uh,
had been doing awesome things. Um,
Pablos Pablos Holleman is one guy. Um,
he's part of this, uh, uh,
group called the Schmoo group.
And when I went to Smu,
Schmoo s h m o o Middle Group,
and I found out about
them when I was like,
when I was a kid and when I moved
to La when I was 13. Um, I, uh,
PABLOS P A, B l o S. Pablos Holeman. Um,
I feel like I went to an event where he
spoke and he had a device that he waived
across the front row of the crowd
and captured all of their credit card
information and their wallets.
That sounds like publish.
This guy is awesome. I mean,
he's, uh, he's down to Earth,
right? Sociable. Uh, these are elements
that a lot of hackers lack. Right.
And I really liked that. I
liked the ability to, you know,
sit down and sit down in front of like
numbers and just unattractive code and
also be able to communicate with people
and actually have a real relationship
with people and socialize more.
Another,
I love being away from computers
for three years, right?
It forced me to socialize. And
if I didn't have that, you know,
this conversation will be very different.
Um,
so I really like Publix just because
when I learned about the Schmoo Group,
I was 14 years old and I was at, that
was the first time at my favorite. Uh,
I had a conference called Defcon,
one of the biggest hacker conferences
in the world is in Vegas every year.
And they had this robot that
would drive around and it had,
it was two big wheels and a screen and
all it did was show you your passwords.
Oh God. Drive up to you wirelessly.
And it would just be like,
this is your password.
And you're like,
what if you had a phone
or you're on your laptop?
It would just sniff passwords in the
air and show you that it was beautiful,
beautiful entire vine. Like so many
things in life. So, uh, you know,
he's definitely a guy and,
and also Dan Kaminsky is another really,
really smart, really, uh, I know
that name for some reason really. Uh,
he's found some huge
vulnerabilities in the internet.
So if you've heard of the Internet and uh,
he,
he had something called the Kaminsky
bug a few years ago where he found a way
that he could essentially
control any domain name.
If you wanted google.com to point
to his website, he could, um,
it seems reasonably powerful. Yeah.
Very powerful. Any, any, you know, he,
he made a huge effort to resolve it
very quickly and effectively. Um,
so I think he's been someone I've watched
at def con ever since I was 14 years
old. And, uh, some of the people attend
difficult on each year. Now it's over.
It's over 10,000.
It's probably like 15,000 per year now.
Is it from the standpoint of a,
a non techie,
I have a severe,
uh,
anxiety related to this. I've heard of def
con for quite some time. Okay. And, uh,
we were talking about, you know, the,
the magazine that you read
for quite some time, 2,600,
2,600,
which I,
which I picked up years ago but
lacked a much to my embarrassment,
sort of the technical chops to
appreciate even though I picked it up.
Uh,
should someone be intimidated and
afraid of going to say a def con?
Yeah. Are there risks involved?
That's a great question.
If you turn off your phone,
you should not be afraid.
Everyone is actually really cool because
I would love to attend. I've never been,
but my fear is that as a non
techie I would just be, you know,
caught with my pants down and bent over
a barrel every which way from Sunday
because I am so easy to exploit
in that respect. I would say,
I would say turn off seriously,
turn off your phone,
turn off your laptop and talk to
people like people a everyone.
It's almost like all the
hackers are among friends. Um,
I know I am like when I'm there it's it.
These are my friends.
Whether I know them or not.
These are,
these are people who have
similar interests, can be
sperm in even you, right?
Even if you find it interesting
enough that you'd want to attend. Um,
and some really smart people,
some really interesting people
from all walks of life. Uh,
but there are definitely
people who are here we go with,
they're called script kiddies
in the community and the heck,
I want you to elaborate on this. All
right? So, yeah, I mean, I grew up,
I was a script kitty.
You know,
when I learned about a denial of
service attack and I had a letter when I
downloaded wind nuke and knew I could
crash someone's computer or that I could
open someone's CD Rom,
that wasn't one of the fun ones.
I can just open any of my friends,
just draw calls or guys to your friends,
the ones that came, right. You know,
just like cop out and they'd be like
surfing the web and boom, see rom open.
Uh, that a, a script kitty is
someone who doesn't necessarily,
doesn't necessarily
know what they're doing,
but they've downloaded some programs or
script that is doing something, you know,
out of, out of there a hacker paygrade
right? It's out of their technical chops.
And that's okay. I mean, that's,
that's how we, how you learn.
That's how you learn anything, right? You,
you take what you can and there's nothing
wrong with using the tools available.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with that. So I,
I don't think you should be a malicious,
I'm not a malicious hacker.
I don't want to a destroyer
or hurt people. Um,
I really want to, you know, sort of, uh,
I wanted to show people the,
the lack of security that exists today
and hopefully help protect them and teach
other people like what they can learn.
So you have, I think in the, uh,
let's just say the mainstream
perception of hackers, the white hats,
just like spy versus spy. I got the
good guy. Sure. We got the black hats,
the bad guys, Eh, the malicious folks.
And then you have the gray hats
or the people in between. Uh,
how do those different
groups think philosophically?
Because like I guess the idea being,
if you look at the stones of the world,
the Hitlers of the world, they absolutely,
and I'm not equating
that to black hat at all,
but I'm just saying they believe
themselves to be doing the right thing.
Right?
So what are the philosophical
orientations of those different groups?
Um, you know, I'd say if you're black cat,
you know, perhaps ignorance, you
know, perhaps ignorance is bliss.
And I've learned that I'm ignorant of a
lot of things when I don't think about
it. If I don't actually take the time
to sit down and think, how does this,
let's say,
effect someone,
how would I feel if I were
in this other person's shoes?
I can remain a grant about something.
Um,
and sometimes you want to write a,
sometimes I don't want to know that. Well,
right? If you're a guy in Las Vegas
who's remotely flying drones in Iraq,
billowing up dozens or hundreds of people,
you think of it as a first person shooter
game. Not as a rival world exercise.
I mean, I gotta be honest, like every
time I eat a steak, I'm like, I don't, uh,
I'm financially not thinking about what
happens. Yeah. Right. More and more.
I do think about this now. Um,
but I love his stake, so I'm like,
maybe I should just be a little black
cat in my food, my food etiquette.
A black cat carnivore.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, Oh man,
I love it. So, um, you know, I'm
being ignorant and now I'm just,
I'm just being silly. But uh,
I'd say yeah, black hats are,
aren't really f and I think
that's true of anything.
If you don't think about how
it actually affects somebody,
then you are doing that. Um,
I'm no more wine. I won't,
there's, there's more wanting to
be had. So I shall pour one. Oh,
what's this one called? Oh, this is a,
this is a somewhat amusing a label and
I may be abusing my housemates wine
collection. Sorry,
housemate. Sorry. Housemates.
So there's a very trippy
tattooed chick on a,
what appears to be a motorcycle
on the label and the brand is,
if you see Kay, I, F y, O, u, s, e, e,
k, a, Y, which spells of
course f, U, C, k, I, e,
fuck,
which is such a delectable flexible
curse word in the English language.
Uh,
for those understood.
There is a book called English as a second
fucking language all about the use of
the word fuck, which is
really, really fascinating.
But I digress and we've killed our
second bottle. Can't wait. Well done.
Good work. Salmon. He'd worked.
So we were talking about,
uh, black cats, steaks.
Uh, another thing you,
were you ever a black hat?
Oh Man. I mean, uh, you know,
I guess people might see
black head differently.
I think if you're trying to
sort of a lot of black hats,
typically what they're doing is
they're hacking for financial gain. Um,
I've never hacked for financial gain,
uh,
except for all the jobs I've
gotten fracking of that,
not hacking maliciously. Uh,
I would say a lot of hackers and
I find a lot of them, you know,
a lot of the black hats were actually
in like Romania and Russia and a lot of
countries where maybe they
don't, uh, I don't know,
hit you so hard for doing that. Maybe
there aren't that many laws around that.
Romania seems to be a real hotbed
for yeah. A lot of that we live,
they have like western union's
every like happy blocks just stop.
Staunching I mean it's
really become a sort of a,
a nexus for a lot of that
activity. Yeah. Yeah. And uh,
that's why I'm Romanian nine
months a year. Just kidding.
It's where your several homeless,
my first home is. No, just kidding.
Um, uh, but I would say so black hats
are typically doing it for financial,
financial gain.
Uh,
and there's so many ways to do it for
financial gain and I learned that a long
time ago. And, um, what are
some of the ways to do it
for, for financial gain? Okay,
so a, for one, stealing credit cards, uh,
hacking into companies is actually,
is almost trivial.
I'll just say that anyone
can learn how to hack. Um,
anyone can learn these things.
And that's one thing that I'm trying
to teach people. It's like how the,
how computers work, how
technology works. And anyone can,
let's say break into a company. If
you try a company that, for example,
does retail and if you do retail,
then you can,
let's say you've saved
your credit card somewhere,
you can then see that database
full of credit card numbers. Um,
and you can then sell that.
You can either monetize it yourself and
you can produce credit cards using a mag
stripe writer and create your
own credit cards and use them.
Or you could sell it to someone else
who already has that. Has that handled,
I mean, there's sort of a little
distribution chain that goes down.
That's one simple example of someone
who could be an entire novice. Uh,
you know what you might call a script
kitty and who can steal databases just
enough to be dangerous of credit
cards and sell it and make money. Um,
this is a huge thing. This is
actually why, you know, well,
this is a lot of what the secret service
does besides protecting the president.
It's also protecting it like money and
online is the easiest way to steal money.
Um, also like as you saw Pablos
right? He probably, he waved,
he probably waived something
as my guests where RFID based,
he stole totally credit card a number
because these are, yeah. Just to,
just to explain one more time to folks,
this was many years ago
to this is not recently,
and he had a small handheld device that
he waved at the front row while giving a
keynote and was able to capture all
their credit card information from their
wallets. Amazing. Oh God.
Yeah. You're just getting credit card
numbers. I mean, the, the beautiful,
beautiful thing about that that are
of id, that RF radio frequency, right?
Same thing is stealing cars.
Um,
you can just walk through times square
and just steal numbers without ever
touching a person. It's insane.
So you can then sell those, right?
There's a black market,
there's a market that we're someone
go to sell credit cards. Uh,
I can give you a list of sites now. Uh,
there, there's a lot of, there's forms,
typically fright, private forums.
There's also government governments, uh,
definitely in those forums as well.
But yeah,
Darwin's who buy those credit cards new
by those credit cards who tried to fuck
track those credit cards.
I had subcontracted for a company
for 13 years ago that,
uh, worked with FBI.
And what,
uh,
what we were doing was tracking
down a huge thief of credit cards.
And they had not only penetrated
a company that had credit cards,
you know, like a retailer.
They had penetrated,
the hacker group had penetrated a gateway.
The gateway is who your
credit cards go through to.
It would be like a stripe or a paypal.
Her and I'll throw size. Exactly. Um,
so it's a credit card processor.
The people who get all the credit
cards from all the money, you know,
all the companies online. And they
had penetrated one of those servers.
And we had found this,
uh,
the FBI told us and we investigated and
we had a little bit of authorization to
hack these Romanians
servers. Surprise, surprise.
So essential misc yeah.
So I,
I essentially chick Foche, I'm spending
a little bit of time rather manuals,
they're fun, fun group talk.
Uh, so they would, uh, Eh, and
I, you know, essentially the,
our job was to track them and find them.
And um,
we did,
after I found this one of the hackers and
found their chat room and chatted with
them and became friends and they'd send
me pictures and I saw this guy's new
viper and is in his garage,
brand new viper cash.
Oh Wow.
Nice Romanian cash horror movie.
It's like new Jack City Style and Romania.
Yeah. And uh, that's how we found them.
And um,
that many crazy thing is so many things
are hacked on a daily basis and we just
don't know. And a lot
of the times, you know,
the companies are required
to tell there were users,
not everyone tells you
that you got hacked. Right.
We hear about hacks all the
time now and it's unfortunate,
but so many companies are
being hacked and don't know it.
What do you think of using services like
a one password or lastpass or whatnot?
Try to improve your security
with passwords? Yeah, that's a,
that's a tough question for
me just because I'm unsure
how I feel about them. Um,
I don't,
I personally don't subscribe to them
just for the fact that they are,
it seemed like a big target, right? If
I were, if I were to high value target,
SVT is, it's a, I would be like
analyzing their code every day,
trying to find a flaw so that when I want,
I could then get,
when I do have computers,
when I do drop some malware on a website,
I didn't get all your passwords, not just,
you know, not just one. So the ideas,
however,
in general,
I think they're doing a good thing because
I believe if you're a person who uses
the same password for every website,
I believe it's superior to use a program
like last pass or I'm a buy and a bean
has a, as another password manager
went on one password, whatever.
Yeah.
So I believe it's better to use those.
Then they use the same
password everywhere. Uh, what
I would suggest to everyone,
that's something I do.
I don't make ridiculous passwords
that are hard to remember.
I make it really easy passwords to
remember and they're just really long,
usually lyrics in the song. Yeah.
You know, welcome to the jungle baby,
exact Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. You know,
favorite puff daddy song,
you know,
Dr Dre and
owe money.
I don't need to choose some lyrics.
Uh, it doesn't matter if there's not a,
you know, crazy like exclamation
marks and like capital letters.
You don't need all that.
If it's really long,
but you'd remember that's much better
than an exclamation mark in the middle for
a short password. And you can
remember it right. For Your Bank.
You use stuff related to blink, you know,
for a different website. Just Oh, what's,
you know,
what makes you think of that website?
What other precautions you freaked me out.
I,
I had mentioned my name before Monday.
We'll know with the hijacking
of laptop cameras. Okay.
So I just got a new computer.
I need to cover up that camera.
But uh, what other precautions would
you suggest that people take? Well,
I'd say there's a pretty
advanced technology that you can,
you actually use to protect you against,
um,
someone invading essentially the
camera. And it recently someone, uh, um,
people have found that they've been able
to enable the Mac book cameras without
the light coming on. Wow. And the,
and supposedly the FBI has
been able to do this for years,
but now it's been found by other people
demonstrating demonstrated. Right. Um,
so there's a pretty advanced technology,
uh,
that came out a long time ago called the
posted and you can fly the posted just
above, just over the camera. And
when you wish to Skype or facetime,
um, you can lift said most
exactly. Or masking tape. Correct.
Which was my, my goto.
Correct. What's, uh,
are there any software
programs or applications that
you use to improve security
or anonymity? Oh, man. On your
computer. This is a weird one.
And this is something that I will,
this is,
it makes me feel funny. Um,
this software can be the one,
there's a software called true crypt.
True crypt. Correct. True crypt.
This is a, uh, software,
uh, it's open source.
It's been developed to help you encrypt
your either hard drive or folder or
flashdrive and it allows you to say, okay,
if you have information on our protect,
you can encrypt it with this
software called true crypt. Um,
it requires a password and no
one knows who created truecrypt.
It's always been open source.
It's probably been a team of
developers and that's really cool. Um,
recently maybe a few months ago the
website changed and it said true crypt is
insecure,
don't use it,
go use something else.
And that was it.
The authors said that and it was done.
This is one of the craziest things.
There were very few.
There are very few products or pieces
software out in the world that are
anonymous that are run by non Hummus.
You know,
a nun's group and that are successful.
Truecrypt is a success.
Lots of people,
when I say success,
I mean people who want
protection use true crypt.
So it's kind of scary to hear
the thing that you've been,
at least if you're in my world,
you would be using true groups if you
want to protect information because it has
a wide base of users of smart users who
already understand cryptography, um,
and who want to protect their stuff
and aren't just using something random,
the off the shelf that just
may or may not have flaws. Uh,
because stope and sourcing me
analyze and audited by other people.
And just recently, probably within the
past few days, an audit of few days,
the past few days,
uh,
an audit of true crypt has been completed
because for a long time people have
been saying, we need to audit your
cup just to make sure it's secure. Um,
and your auto some uncompleted.
And there were some minor flaws,
some flaws that can be exploited, but
nothing, nothing huge, nothing wearing,
nothing. Like, oh, there's
a backdoor in here.
So why do you think that message was
put out? Oh Man, I have no idea. I mean,
the question is did someone,
there've been some interesting
things that have happened recently,
especially with the revelations
of Snowden. Uh, for one thing,
there's these gag orders that we've now
learned about that sometimes the NSA can
send a gag order and say, uh, you know,
we want information and you
can't tell your co your users,
you can't tell the public that we gave
you that we gave you this gag order. Um,
so I think some sites are actually
employing something where they say,
we have never been asked by the government
to provide any information or just so
completely, if they ever encourage
you, get, well, they asked this,
they put this up before they've ever
been asked. Uh, so if they're ever asked,
they have to take it down.
Ah,
so that this hasn't been tested in court.
But the idea is that's clever though.
So no, no. It's like a plausible
deniability thing. Exactly. Oh,
one of the cool things about true
crypt, um, is that true crib,
t r u e C R y p.
T.
Jesus Christ one.
Uh,
one thing that's really interesting
that true crypt is that it has a feature
called the about plies of
plausible deniability. For example,
if you're at a border and
someone requests you to give,
you give them your password, you have to
in border crossings, you, you have no,
I mean they have full jurisdiction,
they can do whatever they want. Um,
so if they ask you for your password,
you have to give it or you can just
like go to Mexican jail. I mean not,
not an attractive option,
generally speaking, right? So,
uh, you can comes back to our losing your
friends and you're losing your thumbs.
Question
14.
So if there's an interesting feature
with true crypt where you can apply to
passwords to hidden drive or I'm sorry,
not hidden drive, an encrypted drive.
So let's say you have an encrypted folder,
it has a password that unlocks it.
And if you go to the border and they say,
give us your password,
you have to give it up.
And now those files are for
them to use as they please.
A true crypt has a feature where you can
use two passwords and it decrypts the
same drive with two different passwords.
So one is a decoy,
one is essentially a decoy.
And the beautiful part about the way it
works is that the data is all randomized
when it's encrypted.
There's no way to prove that you're
using the secondary password.
It's impossible to prove today.
It's impossible. We don't,
we know of no possible way today,
uh,
with the existing technology to show
that there is one or two passwords used.
Most people only use one.
Most people only need one because they
don't care if they don't care if the
government gets this information,
they're protecting corporate secrets for
example, or they're protecting, you know,
private pictures or whatever.
Some people do care and if they do care,
they can use this additional feature
where it uses essentially the same
encrypted method.
And when you give up a password,
there's no way to prove whether there's
a secondary password in use or not. Um,
so that's a really cool
feature I think when,
and I think plausible deniability
is really interesting.
So it really interesting thing
to play with. Super interesting.
I know guys who uh,
these are CEOs of companies who go
to China and they will always bring a
effectively blank net book with them
China because they assume whenever they
check into a half decent hotel in China
that their data is immediately being
downloaded yeah. From their
computers. Absolutely. Uh,
and a man having spent some time in China,
that would not surprise me in the least,
so absolutely. Yeah. I mean just recently,
uh, I mean literally in the
past few days as well, a Goo,
China's a certificate agency.
The people who encrypt all the web traffic
in China gave out a fake certificate
for google.com so that
they get essentially,
oh well they claimed that it
was an accident. Who knows?
But essentially if you're,
if you're using them,
if you're in China and you
go to a google.com domain
or like Gmail for example,
that you believe is encrypted,
they can decrypt everything. Oh,
I read your email for
example. That is a, a,
a very literal example of those
of you who speak Chinese. That is,
it's a whole month, the whole
month. This is taking the back door,
which is Nick's a,
which is an expression used
typically to refer to say,
you know,
bribing officials or something like that,
doing something very unofficial
that gets official results. But uh,
accidents I'm on.
So I'll say when it comes to tools,
if you're looking for more tools,
I keep it private.
It's just my personal list of what I'm
using today and it's if you want to see
it, Sammy dot. Pl slash tools.
This is a rad list. I've,
I've looked at this before.
Gas, so you should check it out. It's
just a Google doc. I keep it. Uh, I don't,
I usually just send it to my friends,
but if people are interested
in what I'm using today,
this is my updated lists of what the
software I run pretty much. Cool.
Send me that. Pl slash slash. Tools. All
right, cool. I will link to that as well.
Uh, do, uh, do you read
much? Do you read? I don't,
um, I, I was about to say
I used to, no, I never did.
No, I've read, I've read, I read
here and there. Um, and I'm,
I hate pretty much what I do is like
I'll read a few pages and I love Amazon
because they let you read a
few pages and if I'm, you know,
if I feel dead dictate
it and sometimes I do,
then I keep reading it.
What are the last books that have
caught your attention that way? Mm.
Caught my attention. Um, were books
that come to mind that have, okay.
Okay. Yeah, I mean lately I've been
like into mechanical engineering,
so I've been re reading
mechanical engineering books,
but I would say things that like
have affected me and changed,
changed me that I think are really cool.
Um,
I would say one book is called
influence by Robert Cialdini.
Definitely. Uh, I learned that about, uh,
I believe it was Stan who told me about
that and when I was 16 and I read that,
I mean this was, canvas came out before
I was born. It was in the early eighties.
Um, Jesus Christ, we wonder,
you're born again. 85. Good God,
young and little sea monkey pup
continue. So sure, sure. Um, so influenced
my age. Come crashing down upon me.
Please continue. Uh, so chow,
uh, influence, uh,
it's a book about influencing and how
humans can be influenced and persuaded to
do things. I mean, I don't know.
I don't recall whether it's a book for
salespeople or for like manipulating
people or how to protect yourself. It's
a little bit of all of it actually. Um,
and I love it because it was a very
systematic and analytical approach to the
most common ways that human beings
have been known to be influenced and
persuaded to do something.
You could use it for sales,
you could use it to attract
people you'd use it for. I mean,
these are life skills. I believe these
are life skills. Definitely scarcity,
absolute time restrictions. Sure. Social
proof have to run to save some penguins.
But I, you're right.
Yeah, yeah. These are,
these are common principles and
that's like ability to write,
to save some penguins, like, like
ability. So the, I mean, those,
like those shaped me. I mean
to, to understand how I could,
and it's not influenced people
in a negative way. I mean,
it can be used that way,
but it's how can I socialize with the
humans around me and how can I like be
friend people and how can I, um, you know,
I'm going to use reciprocity too to
have people in my life who I like and
respect and appreciate and I want
them to respect me back. Right?
I want them to appreciate me.
So how can I use these tactics and
methods appropriately to do that?
What,
uh,
when you need to be in the zone
for coding or anything else,
what music do you listen to?
Ooze this. Okay, cool. That's
a great question. I Love,
love music. I go to, I have new,
a blog, audio moll, uh,
audio, molly.com audio,
Molly audio, molly.com. That's an
amazing, I am, we can take that.
A lot of directions,
Edm.
So it's all a lot of electronic
dance music and um, they have, uh,
it just sort of like the, it's
the latest stuff, but it's not,
it's not poppy. It's, man. I mean,
I don't care if it's popular or not,
it's just if it's really good,
then I really like it.
So I'd say lately I've listened
to a lot of electronic music, so,
uh, I know we've had, man, you had
someone from the glitch, mob Beretta.
Justin, great guy, man. I love
the glitch mob. Yeah, they're
great smile. But I mean,
they came out with an album maybe
a year ago or two years ago,
and there were my favorites. So I
would say that kind of music. Um,
uh, like the glitch mob, I mean,
infected mushroom mushroom.
Yeah.
Another Molly Molly washroom
out. Those guys are amazing.
They play every year.
I'd never heard them play
every year at Avalon.
And they're always in kind of the
latest technology. And they use, um,
like they have these massive, uh,
most Djs, they just hit, you know,
some people say they hit play, some
people say the scratch, whatever.
These guys have these massive,
like 42 inch plexi glass screens
in front of them that you,
as the audience can see,
you can see what they're doing.
They're plexiglass with a projection of
what they're doing on top. That's cool.
Sorry. Minority report. Oh, so
minority report. It's, yeah, it's,
it's a device called the emulator they're
using and they're tapping so everyone
can see what they're doing.
They're on the stage,
live right deejaying and uh,
it's like so futuristic.
It is exactly mine. Your minority
report, you know, in Edm.
So a electronic music cause what else?
New Lot. What was it? Infected mushroom.
Infected mushroom. They've been around
for many, many years in an Israeli duo.
This is really
proactive and they,
they're always keeping up to
date with sound and I think they,
they appreciate quality in their work.
Like I really like that. Very cool. Um,
I'll ask you a question I
haven't asked in a while. A,
if you had to conjure a face and
a name to correlate to punchable
punchable yeah. Okay. What
comes to mind? Oh, I don't,
I don't know. I don't, I don't
usually want to punch people.
It could be a conceptual
punchable man fo of sometimes
Tim. Tim, that's a fair answer.
People want to punch me.
I don't really want to of people shake.
You want to shake him really hard,
Chris? Rock stone. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. I go, I got one.
I don't know who they are. I
don't know their names. All right.
And I'm not upset at them because
I know it's not their fault,
but people making these maps
software's for our phones.
Just having driven with you recently,
this is perfect. When I phoned,
came out, Google maps was
there and it wasn't Google,
it was apple slash Google maps,
which was one of the most beautiful
harmonies I've ever seen. It was enough.
It was the most effective map
software for a mobile phone ever.
And then apple said, no, we
don't want your Google stuff.
We're going to come out with her own naps
and removed this original map software.
And instead of apple coming out with
beautiful software like they normally do,
they're like, here's some shitty
software for you. Copy your hands.
Uh,
and that was awful.
And then Google maps came out and
they came out with, they're amazing.
They're amazing. Google
backend. And then they're there.
They had to design their own APP.
So they had their Ui people and,
and there are UX people.
I'm not sure what Ux people,
but they came out their user experience
and they're like, here's like a seal.
It's trying to tell you how
to like get around town seal
with amazing backend. Like
that's what I think. Oh,
that's what I love about Google.
It's a bunch of engineers but that's it.
I need more,
more than a dozen years there.
I know it's so show me
more than the engineer,
but like I understand
the engineering backend,
but there's this beautiful
creative front end.
It's like people who actually
sit down and use their software.
And it was when I was shaking my phone
in anger recently and I was like yelling
at my Google maps and I was like,
why won't you just tell me where to go?
Why do I have to seven times to get
to a new directions? And it said,
do you have a suggestion for us? And
was like, what are you talking about?
What do you mean? Do I have a
suggestion? How do you know what?
You know what I'm saying? Are you
listening to me as possible? Um,
and a few days later it happened.
He be like a week you,
I shook my phone or naying or
yelling at it. Google maps said,
do you have a suggestion? And
I said, how do you know this?
How do you know I'm upset?
Are you like reading?
Is it like Scientology where the ethic
e meter and they can lay recovery your
like spiritual harmonics or something?
And I was like,
well did they must be like
listening to me. That's not cool.
That's an unacceptable. And then I should
have the phone and it did it again.
I said, oh wow. Someone
who, someone exactly.
Someone at Google was pissed off
enough that they're like, oh yeah,
I Shaked by my phone when I use
Google maps all the time about this.
So I mean,
you know,
I do love Google maps and I love Google
and they do some really cool stuff.
But I, I checked my
phone a lot. You went up,
you want to punch Google
maps and face sometimes. Uh,
what advice, how old are you right
now? Twins? I'm 29. Ooh Man. Again,
old getting old, but, uh, I think
I can reverse it. We'll see.
You've reversed it. I know. No,
I'm working on that. I'm just,
I'm just going to keep up with your
blog and all of my drug regimens.
Uh, what would, what advice would
you give your 20 year old self? Oh,
the 20 year olds subcommittee. Felonies.
Okay. Use a computer.
Idiot. You're sitting there.
What about 15? 15. Oh, okay.
Substance stop wasting time in
school. Uh, wasting time in school.
I mean, it depends who, it depends who
I'm talking to. If I'm talking to myself,
what would I say?
Um,
a man. I mean, so,
so much I could tell
myself invest in apple.
Uh, exactly. Um,
I would say, I dunno, just, uh, you know,
go with the flow.
Like I've always tried to go with
the flow and I learned early on,
I think learning, like reading about
people meditating or something that just,
everything's kind of cool
and everything's okay.
If you allow that to you pretty much
in control of your own destiny. Uh,
I wish I could say that for myself
as much as I like, but you know,
you're controlling your emotions,
so try to not worry about things so much.
Um, and I really try and, yeah,
I try not to worry about things like try
to try to be good and at this point in
my life, yeah. I guess I would
say I would say one thing,
I would say the same thing I said earlier,
trying to do whatever the hell you
want to feel good without intentionally
hurting someone else. That's what I'd
say. That's good advice. So I told myself,
so where can people find
you on the interwebs?
Other eds, your site, youtube,
all of the above. Yeah.
So I'm doing a, her web
doing, you know, one thing.
Now I'm doing a new youtube videos
and a teach and also just write very,
very detailed the write ups and teaching
people how to hack, how to code,
how to reverse engineer, uh, and
also teaching just regular consumers,
everyday consumers who have things
like phones and computers and cars,
how to protect themselves,
um,
and then demonstrating them really
cool exploits and vulnerabilities.
Like how to steal cars. Um,
so I'd say the best way,
ways to follow me, uh, you
can follow me on Twitter.
I'm at Samy Kamkar, s a m y. K. A. M.
K are um,
or follow me on youtube,
which is really old username.
Youtube username, s four, m y.
K. O. Jesus is terrible.
No, no, no. Say it again.
What does that worry is like is like a
in hacker speak. Oh wait, sorry. Sammy.
Can you give it to me again?
It's like Sammy Kay.
But Sammy Kay was taken so I
had to take s four, m y. K. Oh,
that's not so bad. It's, it's
Kinda bad. It's bad that it
could be worse. It wasn't,
he was just like, I never thought
I'd use this for m y k. Yeah.
I used to play like halo and Xbox.
And also as,
as far as a quick side note on Halo,
I had a chance at one point,
I really played halo once before
and then I had a chance to play,
I think he was a world
champion at the time.
A guy named fatality
and just got familiar.
Fucking obliterated. Oh
yeah, he's totally pro.
I think that's all his billboard on,
uh,
like lost like a Highland avenue
and Ho yeah, he's well known.
And I got,
this was a couple of years ago and it's
like wait a second game ever and just
got so manhandled.
It was utterly embarrassing.
Beyond embarrassing. Awesome.
All right, so we got you on Youtube.
We have you on Twitter. I will,
I will link to all those in the show
notes as well. And just anywhere else,
just my website. Um, Sam Y.
Dot. P L a Sammy. Dot Pl.
People can find the tools as well.
You can find all my tools.
Almost everything I do is
open source. It's free. Uh,
I have a mailing list where I just send
me a sneak peeks of new vulnerability
research and tips on how to
protect yourself. Awesome.
This is a super fun. Uh, I,
we needed to do more of these and uh,
for those interested also did a TV show.
We're Samiti guest appearance and a
that shouldn't be available@itunes.com
forward slash timferriss t I m
f e R R I s s to our stresses,
uh,
or potentially on Youtube,
youtube.com forward slash Tim Ferris
also with two r's and two s's.
Sammy, thanks so much man. More fun.
More wine in the future. All right,
looking forward to it.
This episode is brought
to you by 99 designs.
Your one stop shop for all
things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything
from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led
to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York
Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming. A lot of it took place
with designers from around the world.
And here's how it works. Whether you need
a t shirt, a business card, a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and
designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches
and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an
original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward,
and many of you who are listening have
already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some
of my competitions,
some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this podcast is brought
to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to know is this.
I've organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them. You sweat through
them, they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me
the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that,
and Kelly Starr at loves these shirts
as well, is that you can trick people,
they look really fancy so you can take
them out to nice dinners, whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your
luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently, and then pull
it out, throw it on with no ironing,
no steaming,
no nothing.
Walk out and you could probably wear
this thing for a week straight or make it
your only dress shirt and take it on
trips for weeks at a time. Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to four hour work
week.com all spelled out four
hour work week.com forward
slash shirts check it out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash
shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear including the one shirt
that I've been traveling with.
Shirt that I've been traveling with,
shirt that I've been traveling with,
shirt that I've been traveling with.
Shirt that I've been traveling with.
Shirt that I've been traveling with,
shirt that I've been traveling with,
shirt that I've been traveling with shirt.